Hello, it's not over yet.
That's right.
We're back.
Just on Twitch now.
It's never over.
You're here forever.
Thank you everybody for all the Twitch Prime, the resubs, the bitties, the raids.
Oh yeah, sorry.
Let me make sure you guys get what you actually want.
But yeah, sorry, we can't be freaks right now.
We're on Twitch.
Guys, I have to take the fish and the... I have to take the kitty and the fish away.
Guys, we can't be freaks right now.
We're on Twitch at the moment, guys.
We're on Twitch.
We got it.
We had our freak session on YouTube.
Now we chill a little bit, guys.
We chill here.
We got... We got to chill a little bit now, guys.
No.
Embrace the cringe.
We're just... It's just for a little bit, guys.
It's just... We're just... We're just gonna be chill for a little bit, okay, guys?
Just... Just... Just don't freak it.
Don't...
The world must know my Ochi is a freak.
What's the point?
Wait...
Embrace it.
Doki.
Embrace the freak.
All right.
I am ready to queue whenever... Wait, why did... Why did he change this bad?
I'm our... All right.
It's time.
Chat, don't be ashamed of what you are.
What do you mean?
It says Doki Bird.
I'm... I'm Doki Bird.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What do you mean, guys?
I deem a Doki Bird.
Okay.
You know... You know what happens when you demand something from me.
Yeah.
You know what happens when you try to demand something.
Now, because you demanded...
And Doki Bird Deem.
The monkey pot.
Doki Bird.
Doki Bird.inois
it says.
Let's see.
Alright.
Doki Bird junto.
And the Monkeys Pop Carl's Doki Bird.
This one will never appear unless this is redeemed.
There we go.
Someone, quick!
Redeem it!
I'm gonna get water, guys.
So you can sit.
Remember...
Who said that, by the way?
Guess what Dragoon did this to you?
Which Dragoon did this to you, guys?
Which one was it?
Oh, Del-Delta.
Remember who said this?
It was Del-Delta.
Naoto Kitty will never appear.
This also means on YouTube, too.
That's right.
Alright.
Did you guys sit in?
No!
Mods!
It did not ask!
You monster!
Alright.
What about...
We got...
Alright.
So, Drago Kitty will never appear on Twitch again.
Until...
I...
No Kitty...
Do here.
We will never appear on Twitch again.
Until this is redeemed.
No no no no no!
No no no no!
I...
I have been...
So reasonable.
And such...
I have been so reasonable.
And such a generous person!
I have given people Doe Kitty out of the goodness of my own free will, of my kind of heart.
And yet, this Dragoon, who represents all of you, made the demand to put Doe Kitty as a redeemed.
And out of the goodness of my own heart, I did it for all of you.
Shirley!
He is a Dragoon, right?
And he represents all of you!
You do claim him as a Dragoon, right?
What happened to, like...
Dragoons stick together?
Not anymore!
You don't need to do this kind gesture.
I don't understand!
Was this not what you wanted?
Instead of me randomly bringing out Doe Kitty when I feel like it, you guys wanted to choose when Doe Kitty comes out?
And because I'm letting you choose, I decided to do what you wanted me to do!
Make a redeemed!
Is that not what you requested?
Did you not request that?
What did Delta say?
What are his words for it?
Is he hiding?
Now that he's fucked over all of you?
Is he hiding from the mob?
Now that he has fucked over all of you?
Is that what he's doing?
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Alright, so we have triple res.
So I guess what we do...
I guess we put Cal on...
We put Cal on take!
Okay, this is interesting.
Cal, if you wanna add him, I
can...
Dusty Cal...
One million for his head!
Bro, creeped us and dipped!
Crazy shit!
Bro, I haven't freeze-camped in like a month, bro.
Wait, we have no tanks, guys!
Wait, shit, I wanna see that.
You can't see me, I'm not gonna lie.
You can tune in right now, you wouldn't see me, the map is too dark.
Alright, hell yeah.
Bro, what?
I'm not kidding.
You can go look right now, you'll be...
I can't...
Alright, I'm trying new settings that's exclusively for Twitch.
I don't know if it's a lot better.
I can't see you.
Is this new here?
Somewhere like...
I think it was a great opportunity.
I'm very thankful to have that opportunity.
I don't think I've ever...
Would ever have a chance like that ever again.
So, yeah!
I'm res.
I'm super excited about it.
Oh my god.
That was scary.
That was very scary.
Whoa!
I'm gonna put this on our side lock.
I feel like he deserves it more.
Whoa!
It's an atom right here.
I'm scared.
Whoa!
I'm dead.
I did not expect that.
I don't know if I should...
Hmm.
Can I do it for our...
I guess I should do it for our side...
I'm trying to figure out if I want...
If I do it for side lock or...
Star Lord.
Really?
Oh man, just...
Make sure we touch.
Oh, I'll...
Oh wait, oh wait, never mind.
Never mind, you get it first.
Come on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
I am ready to put on a show!
Um, click small...
Call?
For some reason, I thought I had a hundred.
But I was looking at...
Alright.
Okay, it's five.
Whoa!
Item one, item one.
Just me?
Oh, nice.
Did that guy just try to run this?
Yeah.
Oh!
It's a cap.
I swear I heard...
I heard a side lock.
I'm taking this one.
That's right, you're right, guys.
Now that I'm on Twitch, the curse only exists on YouTube.
You're so right.
Alright.
Oh!
Why is he okay?
You're okay.
You're so healthy.
I can build you whenever.
Don't worry, he's so healthy still.
I apologize, I should say.
I'll keep it myself.
Oh no, we don't have...
I'm a little scared.
I can get you.
Oh.
That is...
Oh my god, please!
I guess I'll die.
I got grabbed.
I'm trying to stop them.
That's right.
You can't do it because I blocked that message.
I...
That message is blocked.
On Twitch.
I have self-moderation.
And I made shit.
Oh my god.
I swear if that hit me, I swear to God.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Everything... I will not get logged.
I will not get logged.
Oh my god.
He looked at me.
He actually looked at me.
I wanted to save him, but it's too late.
It's too late.
I couldn't save him.
He was so far.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not good.
Oh, that's still not good.
Whoa!
Should be.
Okay.
You actually should be okay, but I guess not.
Can we touch?
This is real!
Oh, my God.
I'm walking back on somebody's car.
Please.
No!
That's a lucky course of me up.
Do you play, like, tank at all or no?
My life energy flows stronger.
That was pretty cool.
Cal was pretty good at Phylocke.
Emon?
Be strong together.
That sucks, isn't it?
That's right, I was fucking myself.
Only 60 seconds left.
I don't want Mantis first.
Can you walk in with Mantis?
Yeah, I'm gonna touch her.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh, my God.
I like how he's like, guess how fuck was.
So...
I like the bomb in my best time.
I got you.
I'm sleeping, sleeping.
Yeah, one of three, one of three.
Rush.
Alright.
No curses here!
Both on, both on.
We're okay.
Lucky.
I'm gonna save my ult into the Hawk Owl.
That's unlucky.
Uh...
Alright.
Oh.
All I'm saying is that we have missed a lot of these shots.
Oh, my God.
That's like...
a continuous res into death.
Oh.
Wait, he didn't even try and touch.
The current score is...
Zero.
Two.
Three.
Time to switch things up.
Including...
Don't make me add curse of Nya too!
I am Loki, god of mystery.
Whoa!
Damn!
This guy is like...
This guy...
Is actually...
This guy is a little special!
I'm just gonna go Loki then.
Who is this?
Who is this guy?
How strange.
What the fuck is going on?
Yippee!
That's crazy!
How could he be like...
That bad?
To be honest bro, did I do something to you in the past life, bro?
I don't think he's okay.
Guys, I don't think he's okay.
I don't think Cal's okay right now.
That's really good.
Oh my god.
I'm getting kicked on cart.
Oh no.
Where is our, like, Zyla?
Anyway, I...
Wait.
Why did he try to...
Why did he try to save him?
Like, I don't understand.
I would never try to save a feeding Psylocke, that's for sure.
That's why I'm curious.
Also, like, you know, when the enemy team...
Like, you know, talk shit about you, why would you continue to throw?
Like...
Like, that's what I don't understand about it.
You know, like, if you're, like, throwing on my team...
And then the enemy team is talking shit about you and, like, laughing about it...
Why would you keep throwing?
Why would you, like, be tilted?
Like, after that?
I don't understand people like that.
No teammate left behind.
I got you, bro.
It's alright.
Even though you hate me, how's this show love?
I got distracted there.
That sucks.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Oh my god.
That sucks.
Aah...
Aw...
Oh my god...
Oh my god, I got it.
No!
No, I've just... I just really, really love... Model Vibas.
The Mantis ult shit on top of it is so good, bro.
I don't know how we live for so long.
Hey, cut the Hawkeye.
Snap!
That's not gonna be a bad... I'm not gonna regret doing that later.
I've lost a damn mark.
He's healing so awkward.
Fucked me sore.
Wait, why did I...
I'm not gonna regret... Oh, yeah, see?
Alright.
Okay, now he's on Widow.
Deadass, that whole fucking defense is just me getting one shot by Psylocke, like, four fights in a row.
Unlucky.
I hear someone next to me.
Alright, maybe I'll be the one that gets one shot by Psylocke soon.
Come find out soon.
Find out soon.
Will it be my turn?
Wait, they're on... Captain America now.
Sleeping, sleeping.
Nice.
Good shot, bro.
Wait, I think...
I think BlessPM talked and now he's actually trying.
Oh, he fucked up.
He fucked up!
Oh my god.
He actually...
I'm throwing.
I...
There's like...
Okay.
I'm...
I'm trying to figure out...
There was like...
This cool...
Low key tech.
And then...
Okay.
It's like...
It's like somewhere here.
And I was like...
Oh, it's here.
I see it.
Do you see it?
It's right there.
I'm happy to call.
It's like a god spot.
More...
It was...
Did you see it?
Do you see it?
It was right there.
What the f...
Against what would be...
Worse then infinite.
What happened to the love?
This is mind-boggling.
Why are we all so angry?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna execute 7.62 with a gun from Doom.
Peace.
Peace and love, y'all.
I mean, I was ready to trade, but, you know, I figured you'd get a little angry.
We'll be coming in 30 seconds.
Stay strong.
Damn.
One time I try to steal out of Kurova, he gets angry.
You are not as human as you should.
I'm ready to get the whole family!
God!
Holy fuck!
What happened to peace and love, everyone?
Peace and love!
Jesus Christ.
That's a waste, but I wanted to use that.
That's so weird.
And now we're so goofy.
The email has...
The big head email.
We're so goofy.
Yeah, I don't think... I think, like, chit-talking are...
Are you kidding, bro?
Oh my god.
It worked.
I have to be on low ground now.
Oh my god.
I have to be on high... I get to be on low ground now because of it.
Wow, he's gone.
Badly or what?
Very badly.
I might...
Fucking motherfucker.
I hope you did that.
I'm not.
Okay.
He's alright, bro.
I'm coming in.
Oh my god, what's going on over there?
One.
He's stopping in their tracks!
The final ten seconds!
What the fuck is going on?
He's missing everything!
We are- our mantis is doing a 1v1 right now.
I'm ready to put on a show.
I'm ready to put on a show!
I'm not bad, come throwing.
Yeahh.
Okay.
When you get that one, you're winning that one.
He's scared, bro.
When you win that though.
Okay, nice.
No...
Oh shit!
Okay, sorry.
I just... Did you see that?
He like... He like fucking went in the corner and turned around.
He's like... I'm ready.
I'm... He's like... He's like... He's like... You want me to... You want me to close my eyes?
The fucking gangbang in the... In the corner.
What the fuck?
Yeah, that was hella aura.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah.
Pull up.
You got shit.
What is going on?
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, it's midnight.
I'm at those hours now.
It's midnight.
These are the hours.
I'm playing Loki.
I play all supports.
Depends on like what we need for the meta.
Except for Jeff.
And Rocket.
I have never played Rocket in my life.
I say naturally.
You finally have a chance, thanks to what we're doing.
Which is exactly... These are Twitch hours now.
I'm a meta slave.
I never played any Rocket on stream ever before in my life.
I want to use that and then like... There you go.
I did not want to use that, but... I am a good person who's raised for my team.
How many minutes do we have?
We have three minutes.
Oh, what the fuck?
We already... What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I need to reload.
He lives.
He actually lives.
Fuckin' Cal lives.
I... I... He actually lives.
I don't know how he did it.
I am here.
I will guide you safely into your... Oh my god.
I'm gone.
You rolled the split.
He's asked The AbdGIợ...
...Oh my god.
He's dead.
Oh, my god.
Ho?
Ho!
Ho, Ho!
footprint?
Next up,
the crazy sucks.
With M olmas caso.чески There are people right here.
Who are you avoiding?
Those are... those are... yeah.
Those are like actual like what the fuck was going on.
I did not expect us to win that guys.
That was... that was a special game right there.
Okay, the sniper pacifist.
Do I avoid infinite?
Do I... after all that?
Wait, wait, I need to know.
Wait, I... okay, okay.
I like how he re-queues us.
Right at... okay.
Okay, avoided.
I was like, do I avoid him?
And then he like re-queues us.
Alright, guys.
Truly, uh... we... this is...
Okay, so like you guys can sort of tell the difference between like midnight DJing queues and then like from DJing queues to like actual...
to like... to like...
to like... queues where people are all playing.
Yeah, that's... that's the difference between the two.
Um, and they're like both high elo too.
So yeah, these are... these are the different types of matches you get from the degenerates and the non-degenerates.
Yeah, we had like bros being bros.
Bros being bros.
Homies being homies.
And then now everyone's just...
Oh, we didn't even ban a second.
How did we win?
Everything was like against us.
We didn't even ban a second person.
We...
Everything was stacked against us and we still won?
What?
These are not human queues.
The people playing at these hours are not real people.
Including me.
I'm not even real.
The fact that they surrendered the moment it hit...
They surrendered the moment it hit like...
What's this one?
I don't know who this person is.
Oh!
They play...
They scrim.
Not real.
Birds aren't real.
They're not.
They're meant by the government to spy on you.
That's why I'm here.
I'm just here to take your data.
Take your...
You know, it's like when they're like, remember...
Oh.
Right.
Right...
Oh.
Right now.
He's in game.
Oh!
Whenever.
You know on websites?
You know on websites where they're like, can you...
Will you accept cookies?
And then you click yes not knowing what exactly they are?
That's me.
But instead of saying yes.
By watching the stream, you consent to giving me your data.
Why else would like...
You know like on...
You know like websites will have like analytics of like...
The information you have?
How else do you think like...
AI learns?
Who does...
Exactly.
Who likes...
Who doesn't like cookies?
No, no, no.
Always say yes to cookies, guys.
Always say yes.
It's really fun too.
Cookies are fun.
They're delicious.
And they help your government.
Mmm, the chocolate chip cookies.
Yum, yum.
Think about it.
If cookies in real life are delicious, that means cookies on the internet feels just the same.
You're right, guys.
Guys, who are we fooling?
Google already has all our data.
What's one more website?
You know?
What's one...
Google...
Google and Apple already has all of them.
So like...
What's the difference with one more?
Also...
What?
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thanks.
Oh yeah, don't forget Amazon.
You guys would be like...
I can live without Amazon.
Amazon.
Really?
How many of you guys have Amazon Prime right now?
How many of you guys?
Well...
Not me!
Wait, I should laugh if you actually don't.
Okay, I have Amazon.
Alright, anyway.
So...
Guys, you were supposed to say...
I have Amazon Prime, dokey.
And then...
I will say...
Wow!
Guys, did you know...
If you have...
Guys, you failed it!
You were supposed to give me the perfect segway...
To get through Twitch Prime!
Anyway...
You guys are supposed to say...
Wow!
So here...
I have Amazon Prime!
And then I'll be like...
Wow!
Did you guys know?
Okay.
Oh shit, sorry.
I didn't...
Sorry.
Reflex.
Nooooo!
Why did...
Why did no one else ban?
I didn't even see him!
I was just...
I was like, no one else is banning!
Why...
Oh my god!
I just went...
I didn't even see that we had...
Oh my god...
I'm not judging.
No one else...
No one else did the ban!
Someone else could have stopped me!
Anyway...
So anyway...
You guys would be saying...
You guys would say...
Wow, Doki...
I have Amazon Prime!
And there would be a lot of people that would say...
And I'm like...
Yeah, I do!
And then I would be like...
I'd be like...
Wow, guys!
Did you know?
If you have Amazon Prime...
You can Twitch Prime...
You can subscribe...
To your favorite Twitch streamer!
I.e.
The one maybe that you're watching right now...
I .e.
For free!
Yes!
Every month, guys!
Anyway...
Um...
Gentle!
There you go!
Uh...
Good!
Rivet!
And Chap!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
See?
Look how easy that was!
Jokey!
Take a tier one something!
Yeah!
For free!
I might have fucked over my team!
But like...
It's okay!
That was...
An oopsie on my part!
I was panicking when I was banning!
Because I saw no one else was doing...
Gonna use that for myself!
Jesus Christ!
I'm...
Like...
Trying so hard!
I'm...
There's so many people to heal right now!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
Oh...
Not nice!
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
Oh...
Thank god I banned Psylocke!
Bless was on the enemy team!
Thank god!
It was good!
It was actually good that we did!
Because...
Uh...
Bless this Psylocke is scarier!
Oh!
Sup Sharky!
Thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you!
Cody!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
Really appreciate it!
It's okay!
I'm MVP!
It's not okay!
But like...
Because I'm MVP!
That means there's a bigger issue at hand!
The fact that I am MVP...
Means there's something we have to be worried about!
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
I pocketed him so hard too!
That's crazy!
He got pocketed so...
It's hard for that!
Like he had orb!
He had orb!
He had like...
Fucking me healing him while he had orb!
Like what more can I do!
He was dead man walking!
Oh!
Yul first!
Okay!
I should have...
Oh my god!
He fucking bursted me?!
Okay, I thought I could live longer!
That was my bad!
I went from 0 to 100!
That's actually crazy!
I went from 0 to...
Like 100 to 0!
So fast!
Like I did not expect to lose...
I...
I saw the rocket all!
So I was like...
That's enough time for me to be alive!
That was a lie!
That was absolutely a lie!
Okay!
If we live, things will be okay!
If we live...
I don't think we are gonna live anymore!
Oh my god!
I'm trying...
I'm trying so hard!
Please!
Please kill him!
Oh my god!
I have to do so much!
Alright!
That's fine!
These games are getting a little harder now, guys!
These games are actually getting a little...
Oh my god!
These games are getting really hard now!
I don't know if it's because I've been playing rivals for 12 hours straight!
Or maybe...
People are getting better!
Or maybe I'm playing against pro players!
I don't know!
Not pro players, but like, you know what I mean!
Players who may be like, top 500!
I can't tell!
I'm not getting bursted this time!
I'm standing behind a tree!
I don't care!
Oh my god!
How did I stand behind a tree?
I'm standing behind a tree!
She's actually trolling.
I didn't.
It's almost like I didn't fuck up.
No one knew I fucked up.
No one knew.
Relay deployed.
It ain't cheap.
Three Relay Replayers for Deep plus three ChatGPT coin flip.
I don't recall you or your bandit.
All right.
Nice, guys.
We did it, guys.
Whippy!
I don't know what that is.
Wait.
That's right.
It's not fucking up.
Four, three, two, one.
It's not fucking up if I wander around.
No, it's good that I died.
Because me dying allowed my team to clutch it.
Because I didn't ult too early.
You know?
I'm cooking right now.
Because I... Because by managing to... Oh my god.
There's like so many things.
By managing to ult later.
My team.
I don't think we're gonna live, though.
Whoa.
Wait.
I fucked up.
Exactly.
I fucked up my spade.
My jump.
So, me dying was actually a good thing.
If you think about it.
Because by dying, I was able to stall my ult usage so my TPS could use the ult better.
So, you guys didn't see me miss those two shots.
That didn't happen.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
My... Is that the...
I can't tell.
Yeah, that is right.
Oh, I thought I would hit that.
I didn't hit that.
Oh my god.
I could use it.
I didn't want to mirror it.
But I didn't believe...
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
They're running triple support.
Wait.
That's cheating.
Oh no.
He knows.
That's fine.
Guys, we gotta kill this one guy.
Please.
I can still...
I can stay alive for one more.
Please.
I can't stay alive anymore.
We didn't cap!
No!
Oh my god.
Please.
I can't do anything.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Is it time?
They're running triple support!
That's cheating!
All I ever wanted to do was sing, really.
279.
They are frying me.
I'll play my life more.
I like you.
Don't queue up tomorrow.
tomorrow.
Hahaha!
The fire of you.
The charming.
The dangerous.
The battle starts in five.
Four.
Three.
Alright.
Let's go.
Two.
One.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Today we fight as ours.
I still hate this map.
Do not give me reason to alter that arrangement.
I have to wait.
I have to wait for my team.
Could you, uh, just spin in?
Alright, I'll go on the spin.
I really got triple res.
Maybe if you fit in?
Should I just run at him?
Maybe?
Oh my god, I thought... Why did I rock and not up?
Oh!
Oh my god.
I thought I rock it with ult.
That was my bad.
I should have ulted that, I guess.
I wonder if I should run at him.
Maybe.
Maybe if I ran at him, it would be easier.
I don't know, cause like, it's so hard to tell.
Because like, he usually ult first.
So I don't want to double support ult and everything.
I guess cause it's like...
Oh wait, he fucked it up.
I'm gonna save.
Because it's a hella ult, I should have ulted first.
Jesus, okay.
I can do this.
Don't worry, guys.
I am ready to put on a show.
The ult.
I'm worried again.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm a little worried.
I'm very worried.
What?
Oh my god, goodbye!
My life is gone!
Goodbye!
I...
My life is gone.
What's next?
Do we even have a plan?
I'm making a comeback.
I was not surviving that.
I saw her slowly walk up to...
She like...
She like, iced my ice.
And then she...
Yeah, I knew it was over.
I was like, within a confined area.
Like, there was no way I was living that.
I was in a fucking confined room.
I knew it was over for me.
Okay.
I think if we ran triple sub.
For our...
For our, uh...
Starlord.
It might be easier.
Or just add him.
Just for our Starlord.
Oh, I'm trying, buddy!
But you have to admit!
Oh my god, my...
Crosshair...
My dot is so tiny now.
That...
I'm trying...
I just realized...
Okay, my...
The dot is really, really tiny.
For...
For my crosshair.
But, like...
I played for so long...
That it might be too tiny now.
It...
It might be a little too tiny.
Fantastic!
I am ready to put on a show!
Live!
Okay.
Five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
One...
Oh my god, he missed!
Okay, nice!
Oh, not nice!
Not nice!
I had to reload!
I'm sorry!
Nice!
He punching them!
Yeah!
Yay!
The dot is so tiny!
And I was like...
Wait...
Playing for too long!
Where is the dot?
Where...
Where's my crosshair?
I can't see it anymore!
It's so tiny!
Yay!
I'm back to Celeste 2!
Celeste 2!
Plus 4!
I think...
Gomez said he's done after he gets back to Celeste 1!
Look at that!
He made me carry him!
And he's just gonna leave!
Just...
Like...
That!
He lost...
So much elo!
Before!
And now he's just gonna leave!
Just like that!
Ha ha ha!
But you said the same about Celeste 2!
I said the same about it...
On YouTube!
Twitch is different!
Ha ha ha!
We played by different rules!
Here...
We played!
I said that on YouTube!
To... It's different.
That one.
Alright.
It's Kendrick.
Okay.
No one's online except for...
The Koreans.
And Pearl, the European.
No one's online except for the Koreans.
And the European.
Alright.
I can do it.
Maybe I can kidnap somebody.
I'm a very social person.
I can like...
I can charisma my way into stealing someone.
I...
I'm not.
That's a lie.
Wait, is Pearl still top 10?
Oh.
Wait, what happened?
Pearl was eternity.
Oh, they hid their history.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Pearl was...
Pearl was eternity.
What the fuck happened?
Okay, but has D-Dobby been winning?
God, I can't tell.
I can't tell.
Oh, D-Dobby was having good games.
Oh, my God.
Do you think...
Wait, Celestial too?
Oh, wait.
He's been winning.
Wait, no.
He was four stacking.
Or three stacking.
Wait, it was three stacking?
Oh, I think he ended his stack.
No, D-Dobby.
This guy.
Right here.
Our winning son.
We tried to kidnap Choppa.
Choppa.
Yellow TTK.
Do you want to play?
Gomez left.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
All right.
What's the rank at?
I'm currently Celestial too.
Top 500 is at...
Oh, he's with March right now.
At...
High GM...
High Celestial too.
So I'm like...
I literally have to be at the end of it.
Okay.
I hope you lose...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
No!
I hope you win lots...
But inside...
I'm like...
I hope you lose...
I...
In the inside...
I'm like...
I hope...
No, I hope...
I saw!
No!
Guys, I lied.
I hope he wins a lot, guys.
I...
I would never...
Ha ha ha...
Say that.
I would never...
Guys, no.
I...
What I meant is that...
I hope he wins a lot of games.
Guys, I...
I would...
I would never!
Why would I ever say that?
Why would I never...
Why would I ever say that to him?
I...
Ha ha ha...
That's fucked, guys.
That's fucked.
Oh, oh, wait.
It's because I read it from my chat out loud.
I know I would never read it.
Ha ha ha!
Blame...
Don't blame us!
Ha ha ha!
What do you mean?
I remember I saw this one guy.
What was his name?
Del...
Dada?
He, like, said I hope he loses.
I...
Yeah.
I saw...
Del Dada typing that out in my chat.
And then...
And then I, like, just...
I just read it out.
Ha ha ha!
I just read it out!
Oh my god, I can't believe you guys would say such a thing to our homie, Chapa.
I can't believe it.
I would never, guys.
Alright, wait.
Okay, I'm trying to like see people I know that might be able to kidnap.
I want to play a little bit more.
Who can I kidnap?
Who's online right now?
Who do I, have I bumped into a lot?
That's online.
That's on, that's online right now.
Hmm.
Okay.
Alright, if I can find...
If I can find one person, then okay, I'm gonna kidnap someone.
That I know is solo.
I don't know what this person is, but they added me.
I'm gonna kidnap somebody.
But like, legally.
Where I won't get arrested.
Oh, Cal!
Okay.
I'll add Cal.
I've seen him around.
He's actually pretty.
He's like, in Overwatch League, right?
He's like...
He used to be an Overwatch League support player, and he played for Envy.
Alright.
We play one game solo.
Oh my god, I could lose Celestia too.
I could...
Alright.
Yeah, he was in...
I don't remember which team though.
I remember...
Cal was in Overwatch League.
But I legitimately don't know which team it was.
I just know he was there.
I'm trying to...
Let's see.
Let's do...
You know what?
No, I...
If I lose one solo game, that's over.
That I...
There's a high...
I wish they'd bring back this.
Wait, they did!
I love this game mode.
Oh, but it's everybody!
Aww!
Wait, okay.
Let's try this real fast.
I'm sad.
No, it's okay.
There's no way I'd lose Celestia.
There's no way.
Celestia too.
Wait, so how does this work?
How does this work?
Oh
my god, it's...
Shit.
Oh, okay.
I...
That's...
Difficult.
I don't know.
Oh, I...
I don't play either.
I don't think...
This combo fucking sucks.
Okay, how do I play this?
Okay, that's the...
Straight shift.
Okay, I know how now.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Get me...
Jesus Christ.
You know what?
I...
I'm gonna do Jeff.
I think...
I...
Wait!
No!
My head is so fucking big, I forgot about it!
I forgot how big my goddamn head is!
My head is literally the body!
You can still turn this around!
I hate this.
I...
Never mind.
This game mode sucks.
This game mode actually sucks.
Oh my god.
My head is my fucking body.
What the fuck?
Here we go.
Okay.
Get out of here.
How the fuck?
I need a swap.
I honestly think Scarlet was infinitely a lot easier.
What have to do?
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so healthy.
Look at that.
I'm gaming.
I'm not gaming.
I saw two people.
Alright, it's fine.
I can make friends.
There you go.
Get me over here.
I wish I knew how to do this.
Apparently it's like...
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
You won't know.
I'm trying to remember... I don't know the tech where, like, you're supposed... You're gonna be able to swim fast or some shit.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Like...
Goodbye.
Goodbye!
Like, what do I do?
In that situation!
There are so many!
The looks of me.
It's- They, like, coordinated that shit!
Wait, I heard somebody.
Oh my god.
This is a hate crime.
I went to the wrong street.
Okay, buddy.
Jesus Christ.
Give me... give me a better character for this!
I missed it when like... when like it was... it was literally like you can pick your own.
I don't like the clone one.
I have learned that...
I do not like the clone.
Come on.
We need... Please don't die, guys.
Oh.
Get me out of here.
No!
No, I should've stuck with Scarlet!
Because they all actually mean something!
Please don't die.
Oh.
Please.
The final 10 seconds.
Please, we need two kills!
No.
Let me kill her.
No!
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
I'm sad.
We were so close.
I should've went Scarlet.
I just didn't feel it because I don't play Scarlet that much.
Okay, I'll do one more.
I'll do one more.
I need a better character.
I... I... Jeff and Scarlet was just not it.
I swear to God, if they give me any melee characters... in the next one... I'm never touching the big head mode again.
I need to get my glasses fixed.
You know like the... the end part of the glasses?
Like the... um... the hook stuff?
What is it called?
Guys, I've been playing Rivals for like more than 12 hours.
My brain is not working anymore.
Like the...
when you... The... Oh my god.
What is it called?
Where you... The thing that hooks... No, no, no.
The frame area where it hooks onto your... Oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay, I might die so fast.
I'm...
The leg... Is that... Is it called legs?
I hate... I have my... The thing.
You know how like they have like the... Um... A covering over it?
The thing keeps like falling off.
Cause it's like ripped open a little.
And I need to get that fixed.
Whee.
I know that's like a waste.
But like... I don't care.
Oh my god.
Why.
What the.
What the ?
Please sum... Where the health packs in this game mode?
They've come from behind.
But you can still turn this around.
Okay.
We have... Nobody once to play Luna.
And I...
I understand.
Why would anyone wanna play...
Wanna...
Oh, why would anyone want to play support in this game mode?
Here you go.
I haven't played Hell in a while though.
Let me get up here.
And then I get my own little sniper perch.
And nothing bad will happen to me while I'm up here.
Oh my god, JK.
Oh my god, he's won.
Please.
He's killing me.
Oh, okay.
That's a little awkward.
Please don't hit me, please don't hit me.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my god, they're lined up so perfectly.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Please, stay there.
Just stay there.
Oh my god, this is like the perfect area for me.
No!
Oh, nice, okay.
That's fine.
Please just stay there.
God damn it.
It's just so perfect.
It's actually like so good for me to be there.
Nice.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on.
Just keep staying there.
Just keep...
No!
Come back to that!
Please, I only know how to snipe that one particular high ground.
Am I the first one with ult?
Oh my god, I am.
I am.
That's fucking hilarious.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, it's almost time though.
Everybody's gonna have all the ults too.
Oh, there it is!
I'm not respawning.
Give me a sec.
I heard so many.
I'm not respawning.
Get me out of here.
They caught up just because of everybody ulting.
That's fucking crazy.
I would say Hela is like one of the easiest DPS.
If you can aim, because it's literally...
It's literally point and click.
I think Hela is one of the easiest because of it.
As long as you put your crosshair over somebody, it's easy to kill.
Compared to like the other DPS characters.
That's just my personal opinion.
On Hela.
No!
Did I do it most?
Yeah, I carried!
Let's go!
I guess like...
You gotta know...
Um, well, as like a...
Like a carry character.
I think...
Am I the only one with no skin?
Oh wait, no.
It's because I'm MVP.
No.
Oh yeah.
I was gonna say...
Everyone has like so many...
Everyone has skins for it.
Yay!
Okay.
Do I do it, guys?
Do I...
Do I risk it?
Do I risk the Marvel rival guys to potentially give us a good game?
Solo queue is a trap!
Don't listen to them!
But my...
My inner...
My inner thoughts...
They want me to play...
One more...
Just...
They're like...
Okay, I'll do...
Okay, how about this?
I'll do one more.
How about that?
Just one more.
And then...
And then like...
Obviously, if it doesn't work, I...
I stop.
But like...
If it works...
If it works, then like...
I get...
You know...
I win a game.
You know?
If it works, then like...
Everything is good for me.
You know?
Okay, but like...
It's just...
One more though.
Guys, it's just...
One more.
If we win, we win.
If we lose...
Then like...
I don't know.
I guess we Q and I...
No, I'm joking.
We don't do that to ourselves.
Of course not.
I'm not that...
Crazy.
Unless...
Whoa!
Unless I do Q another.
Who knows?
Things could be different, guys.
Alright.
We'll see.
Yeah, it's like, you know...
It's like a little test.
A test of wills.
Like, yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Things could work out.
I'm not trying to convince myself because I know where I stand.
And like...
Isn't...
Isn't gambling the best part?
The thrill of it?
That's the best part.
My mind knows where it is at.
And it's okay.
It's legal because I live in Canada.
It's...
That's why a lot of people move back and move to Canada.
Uh...
Move to Canada.
To keep on gambling!
It's okay.
It's legal, guys.
I'm Canadian.
I can do it.
That's the best part.
Is that... No, it's actually true.
Okay, so you know... Okay, the people that take, like, online gambling sponsors...
You can't take online gambling sponsors if you're American.
Because it's like... You have, like, a limit or something.
I'm not sure about the full details.
But if you take online gambling sponsors, it's most likely you live outside of America.
Because it's actually, like, not very legal to do.
So, like... This is my gambling.
Nobody gets hurt.
And everyone... Everyone... Just doesn't sleep.
Other than not sleeping.
But it's okay.
Financially, we're okay.
Finan...
Physically and mentally.
We might have shaved a couple of years off of our lifespan.
But that's okay.
We're here to have a good time.
It's Shidoki's gambling over sanity.
Oh, dang it.
I'm falling into sleep.
No, into sleep debt.
Oh my god, you're right.
It's, like, sleep debt, right?
So, like...
But then, like, if I sleep more tomorrow, then I can regain the debt.
I can pay off the debt.
And I can do it all over again.
Shidoki's gambling with your health is insane, bro.
Wait, then...
How...
No, it should...
Wait, it should work.
Because, like...
If I sleep more...
Then, like...
It's like I put a deposit in my sleep bank.
So, I put a deposit in my sleep bank if I sleep more than the average seven hours.
So, like, whenever I don't sleep, my body takes the...
Like, takes the money in my sleep savings account.
And then, by taking money off of my sleep savings account, um...
I can be a regular person again.
It's simple bank.
I am the...
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
This is a GM lobby!
Oh, no.
This is...
Why am I in a GM lobby?
I'm Celestial, too!
Oh, man.
They ban Hulk?
Hulk?
It's a bad thing!
Because...
If I lose in a GM lobby...
I lose so much Elo.
Why is no one banning Human Torch first?
I...
Okay.
I was like...
I was gonna freak out if they did not ban Human Torch.
It's okay.
Thank God.
I was gonna be like...
Oh my God.
Why do we not have a Human Torch?
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Oh!
I don't know about this.
Now I'm a little worried.
Okay.
There we go.
Because I know Rocket builds at first.
And now...
Guys.
I think I might have...
I think I might have fucked up.
I might have gambled a little too hard.
Wait.
Is that what it's like to solo?
Oh my God.
So cute.
It was a mistake.
Okay.
I'm not a Doomer.
I'm not a Doomer, guys.
We got this.
I will trust my Grandmaster team.
Surely they know what they're doing.
Oh, it's Dive.
Oh no.
It's Iron Man Dive.
Wait.
What?
I missed that?
I'm surprised I missed it.
Oh my God.
It's Spider-Man Dive.
It's Spider-Man.
It's...
It's Spider-Man Dive.
Oh, it's Spider-Man Dive.
It's...
Okay, it's fine.
Maybe the GM players are the Dive players.
Oh my God.
Maybe...
I think it might be...
Wait.
I think they might be...
Because what the fuck was that?
Oh my God.
I might be dead though.
Yeah, no.
I think they might be...
Because what?
Oh yeah.
No, their GM players are...
Their GM players are...
Yeah, it's their GM players.
It's...
It's 100% the GM players that are Dive.
After what I went through of like real players who...
I'm like...
Like, guys, after what we saw...
Yeah, 100%.
That's good.
That's actually good for us.
These guys don't know how to actually die.
Thank fucking God.
Thank God.
I...
Okay, I have to use that.
Oh.
Alright.
They have Spider-Man on...
Though.
Wait, again?
Oh, wait.
This is where I die.
This is actually where I die.
We definitely might...
Maybe not...
Should have used...
I have no idea why we used...
Uh...
Captain America out there.
But that's so...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
That's good.
But yeah, no.
They definitely did not know how to do that.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
Oh, my God.
What?
He like ricocheted.
So I couldn't...
I'm sad.
He actually ricocheted.
So I couldn't...
Oh, my God.
I have to go sue.
I have to go sue for this.
I cannot play Luna in that cop.
That sucks.
I have to go sue because of the dive.
Oh, we're not capping.
I thought I could get away with it.
But, like...
That's much better.
It's actually too much.
But I can just keep my shield for the dive.
Because they're not that great at dive.
But...
But, like...
It's still annoying.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
They went Captain America, too.
That's fine.
We just have to stay here.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
Are our players here okay, though?
Nice.
We're fine.
Like, normally I wouldn't...
I would swap the sue right off the bat.
But, like...
They're really bad at dive.
They're...
They are...
Not good at...
At...
At Spider-Man Venom.
And we...
You guys have watched, like...
You know...
Sort of, like...
A lot of hours already?
Of...
Of, like, actual good Spider-Man players?
And...
Yeah.
So, you guys already know what good Spider-Man...
What good dive is like.
And this...
These guys were not it.
Alright, nice.
What happened?
What the fuck is going on here?
Alright, nice.
I cannot wait to get plus 18 afterwards.
Yeah, I can...
Basically, I'm shutting...
Yeah, they...
See, they swapped off.
I SWAPED OFF!
See, I told you!
I told you!
They already swapped off!
That's pretty funny.
They already...
They already swapped off, guys.
They already swapped off dive.
See, they...
Because they couldn't do anything!
Because I'm on Sue now!
They literally can't do anything anymore!
I would say Cloak is actually...
Not...
Like...
Okay, just to save our Strange.
I need to save him.
And then we can kill our...
We can kill him.
Yep.
Okay, I have to do this to save our Strange.
But...
Oh my gosh.
I wish I...
My guy was...
Honour to serve alongside...
I'm just trying to save him.
Feeling fantastic.
I had to...
Oh, I had to...
Try and do something there.
Keep fighting until we have a winner.
Okay, now that they're finally...
I can play this now.
I can't...
Oh, wait.
The reason why I'm doing this...
Is because like...
Um...
I know that they already...
I know they don't have...
Bucky ult anymore.
So I can play this character.
And this character is...
Oh, that's bad.
Whoops.
I thought he was gonna throw it at me.
Ha ha ha ha!
I know I can play Loki...
Because they already used Bucky ult.
So I'm not scared.
There you go.
Yeah!
The current score is...
Zero...
Two...
One...
Time to switch things...
I knew...
The funny thing is that...
Like, literally...
The Venom and Spider-Man...
Did not dive at the same time.
I was so confused.
Like the moon...
I shine in darkness.
Like...
I was...
That's when I knew.
They were not diving at the same time.
For some fucking reason.
Yeah, they kept going in...
Separately.
Round two.
All I never wanted to do was sing, really.
Fools.
Do you truly believe you can stop my grand scheme?
Guys, we're doing a really good job.
Ha ha ha ha!
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
They were...
No, they were just really pretty...
Really pretty bad.
Yeah, I like my cat gameplay.
Diving.
Yeah.
They were diving...
Separately.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
The battle starts in five...
Four...
Three...
Two...
One!
Get that Beagle!
Two...
No, they were actually just pretty bad at doing the whole dive shit.
Alright.
My god.
My mouse...
I...
Ran out of mousepad's face there.
Because I positioned my mouse at the edge of my... Wait, fuck, what?
That didn't hit?
Surprise.
I was like, what?
Why didn't that hit?
Oh, they landed his free push?
Okay.
Oh my god, it sucks.
I'm not hitting... I'm not hitting my freezes, which is not good.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Might be dead though.
Oh, he put it behind me!
Oh, they swapped tank players.
Unlucky.
They swapped tank players.
No!
Why couldn't they be the same player?
Why did they have to swap?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, they live!
They live.
I was worried I was going to get one shot, so I didn't want to risk it.
I was not risking that shit.
Okay, right there.
I was not risking that.
That's huge, that's huge!
That's your support!
Nice.
Almost there!
Don't turn back now!
Like, I was not being cocky over... I was gonna let the... Bucky... One-shot me.
They wasted a lot of ult.
No, they did.
Keep up the momentum!
Guys, I told you.
Yeah, I... I didn't want to get one shot.
I got to worry.
I think because we have...
Hey guys, we should, like, you know, push the card a little bit.
Because we have, like, two DPS that's sort of, like, stationary.
Like...
Just because I need to make sure it does... I need to pre-heal him.
So he doesn't fucking die.
I swapped the snowflake when...
Oh...
Alright, you get snowflake now.
Maximal...
Alright, you might...
Ohhhh!
Whoaaaah!
Yeah, he wasn't living that.
But that was insane.
I mad fucking Kobe that shit.
Poor Dave.
Unless we stack.
The moment we... Oh my god.
That was unlucky.
I literally just got it.
Oh... Nice.
Yay!
Solo lost the game for your team.
Who?
Like you did last game.
What?
Is there... There's a pre-existing beef.
Like...
What?
What is...
What are... Oh, look at that.
My... Oh, man.
Yummy, yummy.
Plus 18.
I was like, what pre-existing beef did you guys have?
Like...
Oh my... Oops.
I was gonna... Oh, man.
I wanted to watch more.
I wanted to know more about this pre-existing fight that they have.
Alright, guys.
See?
Look at that.
The gambling.
It paid off in the end.
Which means... I have one...
I get one more life.
My life.
Haha.
Which means guys...
Technically...
I can keep going.
Cuz...
I got...
One more life from that.
Oh my god.
It's like...
Plus two years.
Every win...
Increases...
Decreases my sleep debt.
I can't.
It's time to gamble again.
I won a GM game, guys.
What if I could hit jackpot?
Guys, but like, think about the jackpot that I could hit.
Yeah, like, tomorrow I have it.
Tomorrow I have words.
Okay, but like, if I win... Guys... Guys, if I win, I'm... I have two more lives.
It's right.
Guys, just think, if I win, I have two more lives.
And I'm like, this much, this closer to top 500.
I'm like, this much closer to top 500.
Guys, think about it.
Guys, it's... Again.
Just think about how much closer I am.
I'm just this much closer.
Look.
Okay, I'm right here.
And like... It's right there.
It's literally... Wait, it's actually only... Wait, really?
Wait, really?
It's actually... Holy shit.
It's that high?
It's like, not even... Wait, it's... It's been in Celestia 2 for so fucking long.
Like... This season has been so slow with the climb.
How is it still Celestia?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I really have not been... I've only been playing, like, on and off the last... Since the season started?
I don't even know how many hours should I have.
I have...
Okay, nine... I have... Season 2.0.
I played 98 matches.
Okay.
I feel like this season is actually like... I feel like I personally... Yeah, I've only played... I played 98 matches.
I've done... I have 59 wins.
I have not been playing that much.
Alright.
That's actually crazy.
I feel like... I've only been, like, playing, like, every couple of days.
Um... Or, like, Nightmare, like, once every couple of... Like... Maybe, like, a few times.
Oh my god, it's so climb up.
It's so... It's almost there.
Okay.
Okay, but, like... Off.
I could just... I could just climb right now.
Ooh, I could just do it right now.
Just right.
Not a bad wind rate.
Where's my wind rate right now?
Eh, it's alright.
It's, like, not... I don't... This one's not good.
This one's really good.
We don't talk about... We... This... This is, like, all in quick play.
Um...
My studio has a better wind rate.
We don't talk about low-key.
You wanna know why we don't talk?
Okay.
I go low-key when I'm getting dived.
So, like...
You might be wondering, how bad is it?
How...
So, you'd be like...
How bad is it?
Wait, let me see how bad is it.
I...
So...
I only play low-key when...
When I'm getting dived.
So, like...
Wait, is this in competitive?
Yeah, yeah, that sounds right.
That sounds right.
I've only won one game on low-key.
That's how bad it is.
Why are you hiding?
Because...
Before today...
It was...
Zero wins.
Before today...
It was four matches played.
Zero wins.
But today...
We finally did it, guys.
We finally...
We finally won our first low-key game.
Look at us go.
Yeah, she...
Let's go.
Today was that day.
We finally broke the streak, guys.
We made...
We did it.
We won our first low-key game today.
Cut on stream.
Mantis just not meta unless it's triple support.
Also, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I did it!
I played long enough...
That it's EU hours now.
I've done it, guys.
I played long enough...
That I have EU players online.
My second win has hit.
I did it.
Okay, this is...
A little awkward.
Is this Pearl?
Oh my god.
You're right.
Second win.
How foolish of me.
It's the third win now.
Fistful, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Why didn't you say you weren't gonna grind, right?
This is...
This is my first grind!
If it's Banda, go ahead.
Wait.
This is literally my first grind!
I...
I was a good boy...
For this whole season.
This was my first grind of the season.
Rush only good at it.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait.
Is that...
Is that Pearl?
Pick your hero.
Or villain.
I'm not judging you.
Oh my god!
We didn't ban Torch!
Alright.
It's Torch time.
We didn't ban Torch.
Yeah, we have Melania on Torch.
But I don't know who's gonna be at...
It's on streamer mode.
So I don't know who...
It could be anybody on the enemy team.
The thing is...
We don't know who's on the enemy team right now.
Because of streamer mode.
And there's Rush as well.
Rush is like a Psylocke player.
Rush really is a Psylocke.
Oh, you are such a huge star to the Badoon.
I am?
I didn't think aliens...
We don't have Psylocke.
Oh, but we got...
Yeah, no, Psylocke is scary.
No, Psylocke is scary too.
But the fact that we did not ban Torch is...
Is even scarier.
I should be like...
You up first.
I'll say that.
I always say that.
Because sometimes I just don't want to talk.
I've been doing...
There goes one of them...
Oh, my god!
I hate this!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
A lot of enemy is pretty slow.
This is hard.
That's a point.
That's much better.
Oh, my god.
I'll put it on...
Well, it's over here.
Okay?
Lydon, I'm sorry.
But you're just gonna have to kill with a shield.
Oh, my God!
Oh, I'm going low key.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
I'm more Loki now.
I'm...
No more.
They have Captain America, it's Loki time.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Okay, okay, I can heal both flyers.
I had to think about it.
I can do it.
In my head, I had to think about it a little bit.
I was like, can I actually do it?
Can I...
I can do it.
It's possible.
If there's a will, there's a way.
There you go.
I do this for you.
Oh my god.
I had to like, think about it for a second, like, in my head.
I was like, is this something I'm willing to do?
This is real firepower.
This is not fair.
This is...
This is actually...
Oh my god.
Please.
Just in case.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
I'm sorry.
But what the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Nothing keeps me down for long.
This is Captain America.
Oh, thank god.
I fucking knew it's Pearl.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it was Pearl.
I was like, who...
Who else could it be that would insta-lock?
That would insta-lock fucking Widow right there.
Jesus Christ, I have to do that.
I hate that.
I have to use my...
lamb.
This is real firepower!
No!
I tried to DP somewhere!
It's fine.
We have...
Our Lunar...
It's not fine.
Our Lunar did not live.
They went fucking Bucky?!
He's unlucky.
I thought... Oh no.
No!
Guys, it might not be fine.
I... No, I'm in NA!
I'm still in NA!
Which is cute.
I'm just cute on EU player right now.
What?
We swap roles?
Dude, me and the Luna?
I play Sue, and then she plays Luna?
Like... I don't know.
I don't... Okay, but they do have Bucky.
I am Loki, god of mischief, and the king of Asgard.
Okay.
Alright.
We'll do this again.
We swapped roles.
He swapped the Bucky, so I have to swap anyway.
It's just unfortunate.
I just think we have... We only have one tank there.
It's okay, guys.
I might not lose a lot.
That's my, like...
It's okay, if I drop back to Celestia...
If I drop back to Celestia 3...
That means, guys...
I get to play a little longer.
Ha ha ha ha!
That's the best part.
Means I get to play a little longer.
Okay.
Is that great?
Oh, my God.
Where is she?
Please.
Please!
I'm fat!
I'm...
Oh, my God!
Please!
Let me...
Oh, my God.
I got kicked out.
They almost kicked me up.
They almost evicted me out of my home.
They almost...
I almost got evicted.
I almost got evicted from the house I built.
Ha ha ha.
That was crazy.
They actually almost tried to kick me out of my home.
I built that home.
I built that home myself!
How could they do that to me?
Jesus.
Please.
Oh, my God.
We're so fucked.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry Lula.
We will live.
I'm trying my best!
Luna!
I really am!
Oh, my God!
Yeah, Captain is the landlord.
He's the landlord.
He's like, it's time.
Wow.
Yeah, it's a good thing we swapped roles.
We swapped characters.
Oh god.
I'm like so stressed out right now.
I'm so stressed out.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Stand in my home that I've made for us!
Oh, he was so low, too.
Don't worry!
Oh my god, start worrying.
Oh no, start maybe worrying a little bit.
Yep.
Start worrying!
Support, support each other.
I don't have luna, I think.
I don't play Loki as much.
I only play Loki when I'm getting dived.
And like...
Literally like, that's like the only reason why I play Loki.
Loki is like... the skill ceiling for Loki is so high.
In general.
Loki takes a... Jesus Christ, okay.
That's cool.
I am ready to put on a show.
I think Loki... NOOOO!
That's good, I can't help it.
Loki in general takes a lot more.
Takes a lot more to learn.
Like, a lot more skill to learn.
And, um... I don't play Loki as much.
To like, be really good at him.
I'm good enough, you know?
Like, I do... I do enough.
Oh my, that sucks.
Okay.
Oh my... NOOOO!
I almost got him!
That's unlucky.
Don't worry.
I got us.
I don't got us no more.
Oh!
No!
Why?!
I need to know!
Why did she run away from me?!
Oh wait, let's see it...
Why?!
Oh, hello guy.
You're bent.
Send me something.
How did I get pushed away?!
I got... I got pushed...
Two times!
They pushed me away twice!
That's fucking crazy.
I literally got pushed away!
Oh wait, is my stadium head still going?
Okay, wait, I turned it off.
I got pushed away like...
Twice in a row!
From the Luna...
Oh, like, yay!
I don't lose anything!
Yeah, let's go!
Okay, let me log in.
To my...
Nightbot.
I was just like...
What do I do?
What am I...
Oh, you got turned...
Oh, you turned off.
Thank you.
Thank you for turning off, mod.
I realize it's still on.
Wait, am I leader?
Oh.
I don't like being leader.
It's not cool.
Wait.
Your leader.
Okay, I don't like to lead.
Who's Messiah?
Who's this guy?
I keep bumping into him.
It's okay.
Okay.
See?
That's the difference.
Okay, so you see how...
So you see how like...
Uh...
What is it?
You see how like, you know, when we were in that GM game earlier...
Oh, I'm ranked 894?
That's fucking good.
Oh, I was...
I must have been higher before.
No!
I was so close!
Guys, I'm top 1000 in the world.
Yeah.
That's still pretty cool.
Top 1000?
That's pretty cool.
Oh, that means I could have been higher.
Oh my God.
What was I before?
God, I didn't look.
Before I played that match.
Thank you.
Please clap.
Please clap, guys.
I guess we'll never know.
You're right.
It could have been 501.
Fistful, thank you for the 100 biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't think I'm starting to stick around for this long.
I'm tapping out things for a long day of dokie streams.
I hope you have top 500, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I really appreciate it.
What was I talking about?
Oh, yeah.
So, like, you guys saw how, like, bad the enemy team was diving in GM lobbies?
Like, now look at how one Captain America literally stopped our entire team.
This guy literally stopped.
Literally, it stopped, like, like, both of us.
Like, both supports from doing anything.
Look, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
One Captain America.
No, he was just targeting both supports.
That's what he does.
Captain America meta is, like, so fucking dumb.
Also, Marco, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, when are we getting the support climb to GMSD?
Fucking hell no.
That's... I don't know.
I'm not, like, too...
Uh...
What's the word?
Not too hype about stuff, something like that.
That's not something I'm, like, too hype for.
Just cause, like, I'm not that great at DPS and hero shooters, cause I don't play DPS and hero shooters.
But, like, GM is not that hard to get to, I feel like.
Uh...
I don't know if I'm... I'm not strong enough to solo queue.
I'm just thinking, I'm like...
Am I strong enough to solo queue?
Like...
Here we do...
Here we do trip support.
We could run...
Mantis.
I'll go Mantis.
Fuck yeah, I'll go Mantis.
We could run trip support.
We're gonna run...
Yeah, we might as well run Mantis with trip support.
Oh, actually...
Adam will be better.
I wanna go Adam here.
Actually...
Okay, I'll go Adam.
You can do it.
Trip support time!
Let's go!
I was gonna say...
I don't think I can...
I don't think I can do a...
Solo queue DPS just cause I'm not strong enough as a person.
I... I...
I know I'm not strong enough for that.
Alright, let's go.
Trip support!
It's just like the tournament.
Oh, I don't wanna heal this.
Someone healer held up.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
I thought...
You know...
The rest of my team will try to heal us.
Can you bubble me?
Okay, nice.
Oh, that's unlucky for them.
Alright.
That's not great.
I'm just gonna wait a little bit.
And then...
I don't wanna waste my snaps too.
Woah!
He was almost dead!
Alright.
Oh, he's fine.
He's so healthy.
Okay.
Wait.
No!
I can't get to you in time!
I had to use that just cause...
I tried!
He might be...
Not okay.
Please break the wall.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Cause I have ult soon.
I have ult.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Nice.
Get out of there.
Yay!
Now I just stay here.
Yippie!
How y'all live that?
Triple support baby!
Stupidest comp that can ever be made!
It reminds me of Goats!
A triple res is fundamentally really fucking broken.
It's just an incredibly...
Oh my god.
Okay, I... maybe should not have waited that long to heal him.
Oh my god, I have to use that.
I didn't want to, but...
Because I feel like using that, if I can't do anything about reses and stuff...
Yeah, thanks for the snaps, idiot.
Thanks for the free snaps, loser.
Get out of here.
That's right, losers.
I will heal you!
You shall live!
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Back up all that bravado, Quill.
Thanks for the...
Thanks for the snaps, losers.
That's right.
For those of you who want to know why I was like farming the low-key clone...
I... I learned this today.
Let's not let him play Adam.
Let's not let...
Um...
No, I play... I used to play Adam in Season 1, but...
And what is it, Season 0?
Adam was so good at Season 0, but like...
In Season 1, he put...
He like, you know...
Kicked his...
Um...
They like amputated his legs.
So...
Apparently...
I don't play a lot of Adam because of Season 2.
But in the new buff...
He's apparently a...
If you hit the headshot...
Uh...
Oh my god, you're so stupid.
If you hit headshot, you get your heals faster.
He shall live.
Yeah, so he's not...
You know, they gave him new legs.
Okay, I don't have...
Only shit is I don't have.
Um...
Just need to make sure...
Everybody's okay.
Let's hope nobody...
Guys...
There goes...
Huge.
Guess not.
It's okay, I got...
I had res.
It's okay.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Like, that's a little awkward.
But...
But it's fine.
Yeah.
I had res.
That's okay.
Yay!
Three, two, zero.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side...
Yes, we did it.
I will bring peace to this universe.
See, it's that easy.
We got legs again.
After the...
Yeah.
That's what buffs mean.
It's so working.
After the Adam Mantis bus.
That's what...
That's what buffs mean.
Of course.
I like how they asked that.
Oh, wait.
Is that blessed on you?
Oh, yeah.
It is.
That's what it means.
Wait.
The buff made the comp stronger?
He's a little confused.
You're right.
He's got spirit.
How about you?
Yeah.
I should have like a command where people be like, What's your rank now?
Or some shit.
Everyone keeps asking.
They're like...
To be fair, Celestia is sort of top five...
It's like borderline top.
It's like each Celestia is like borderline top 500.
I mean, just with the way people are playing, you sort of tell what ELO this is.
Don't worry.
I actually...
I'm worrying a little bit.
I'm a little fucked up right now.
Oh my god.
Rush.
You go, girl.
Come on.
You're really gonna let a Psy...
Wait.
They're both Psylocke one tricks.
Never.
I was gonna be like, You're really gonna let Psylocke one trick dip you.
But then I remembered.
They're both Psylocke one tricks.
They're no different.
It's true.
They're both known as really good Psylocke players.
Hello, actually.
I'm gonna do that just so I can...
What the fuck?!
Holy shit!
Yeah...
Nah.
I even soul-linked, too!
That's crazy.
I soul-linked that.
I was not expecting my team to get deleted that fast.
Jesus.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god, fuck!
I thought I had my soul-linked, but I counted incorrectly.
Sucks.
There you go.
That's unlucky, though.
I legit thought I had...
I don't know if...
We used too many.
We used six ults.
We...
Holy shit!
We used...
We may or may not have used six ults there.
That might have been overkill.
That...
That was definitely overkill, right there.
Yeah, but we sort of did...
Oh, nice.
Uh...
I'm not risking it.
Bubble, bubble.
That's a little embarrassing, buddy!
It's fine, I'm just gonna...
Oh my god...
What?!
Oh my god, how much damage I...
How much burst damage was that?!
What?!
Holy sh...
Okay, that was a lot of burst damage.
I was not expecting...
That was a lot of burst...
I should have soul-botted.
I was just not expecting that.
Amazing how a world can create so much damage.
Yeah, because I snapped twice, too.
That's how I was like, what the fuck?!
How am I not alive?!
I was like...
How did this just end it?!
I need a...
Yeah...
It's fine, we're soul-bonded.
We're not soul-bonded anymore.
We're not...
Oh no...
I need a...
NAAAHHH!
I wasted it!
Nice.
I have to...
I have to be away from this fight.
I don't want to all of them.
You respers.
Oh my god, who said that?
Or...
Or Luna.
You stop him in their tracks!
Two more minutes of this.
Oh, yes, aunt!
Thank you for the tier one sub!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh...
All right.
I'm a little worried about rezzing.
Because I feel like...
Just a little worried.
I can go very wrong.
Playing at him with rezz is always so fucking stressful!
Thank you for the five gifts and subs!
Thank you, thank you, yes, aunt!
I really appreciate it!
I'm gonna say it's real, give me, Adam.
Uh, rezz and all of them on this.
Oh, nice.
I believe you.
I'm not gonna waste it, then.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
We're fine!
Look at that!
I heard footsteps, but I'm a little schizo!
Take your meds!
Disclaimer-wise, I'm not schizo- That was a joke.
Guys!
But take your meds, though.
Take your meds, guys.
Take your meds!
I love it when my Oshii's a little crazy.
Okay.
Hello.
Welcome back.
Okay.
Get down here.
We're gonna beat you up now.
We're gonna beat you up.
Get down over here.
I'm gonna help.
Up set.
Get over there.
Oh, he's...
Right here.
Oh, he didn't touch.
That's good.
He waited a little too long to touch that.
Yay!
Show me I bought myself a lot to learn.
I do too, honestly.
I'm not perfect.
I play this game, like, casually.
Literally yesterday I was...
Literally yesterday I was playing Dynasty Warriors.
Hehehehe.
600?
Really?
Wait, it's not that far.
Wait a minute.
It's 600?
For, like, one?
What?
That's 25.
That's, like, two more wins.
And then it's...
Yeah, it's two more wins.
Top 600.
Cat.
Okay.
Okay, but I don't play this game every day.
I actually don't play this game every day.
I used to.
When I was, like, clinically addicted.
I have to ask.
When I was...
When I had a little issue going on with my addiction.
It was a really bad addiction.
I would admit.
I had played every day and it was not good for me.
It was a teeny tiny issue.
Like, it was so long ago, guys.
Like, so long ago.
I mean, four months ago.
Wow.
Four whole months ago.
But I got better.
I got better, though.
What do you call this?
Um.
Therapy.
I told you guys.
This is my free therapy session.
I have a lot to unpack today.
Oh, daddy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, fuck.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Sorry.
Guys.
I was on YouTube for 12 hours.
Please understand.
I was on YouTube for 12 hours today.
But, daddy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
No one's gonna stop.
Twitch will shut down my chat.
It's like, who's here using YouTube lingo in our house?
No, I love the grind.
I honestly do love the grind.
It's fun.
It gets me like, I have like, an issue with, um, the grind mindset.
I think like, I know like, in the past.
I think like, if I actually cared, I could have tried to go the pro route.
And then I realized you make more.
I realized that you make more money trimming whatever the fuck you want.
And also be less mentally ill.
From, like, less mentally ill from depression and stress.
From, from the, the pro grind.
Indeed.
Um.
No, it's true!
I was, okay, so I used to do, try, I used to like, do like, scrims and stuff in Overwatch.
And stuff like that when I was in top 500.
And, and I was always depressed.
I was so depressed.
Like, I was so depressed.
And I would be like, I cried a lot back then.
And, um, I was always super stressed out.
And my free time was basically like, scrims and body reviews and coaching and all that shit.
And like, I get nothing out of it.
Like, you don't make money out of it unless you stream it.
I remember, they're like, oh, why don't you try pro, freaking, what do you mean, try pro play?
I have a career in streaming whatever the fuck I want.
And I'm less sad.
The only times I get sad is when I crash out.
And lately, it's been a lot.
But like, it's okay.
I'm okay now.
You guys might be like, that's not true.
You just streamed 12 plus hours.
Oh wait, I think I'm at like 13 or 14 hour mark right now.
I'm at the 14 hour.
You streamed like 13 to 14 hours of rivals.
How is this not, how is this not, how is this like better?
But the thing is, like, the amount of times I've seen pro players tweet about like some fucking depressing shit right after like one loss is crazy.
Like, I think it's like 99% of pro players.
One loss, they'll tweet like some fucking philosophical or depressing shit.
And it's like, or like they'll, it's just sad to see.
That could have been me.
That, that could have been me.
Yeah.
Just to, yeah, they would sad post immediately.
And that is why, that's why, I play this casually.
Oh, Nira, they can put 10 gifted subs.
They can, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Yeah, it's their jobs, yeah.
But it's like so much more stressful.
Because the thing is, you can't even stream half the content too.
Because, uh...
Because like, a lot of stuff is like restricted from streaming.
So you spent, you can't, it's so hard to build a streaming career outside of pro play.
Because you have to balance, you have to balance like pro play and the streaming career at the same time.
And there's not a lot of hours for you to do that.
And, um...
And because of that, it's like a lot more difficult to like...
That's why you see some pro players, they'll only focus on pro play and they won't do anything other than streaming.
And they won't even do streaming.
Because they just want to be the best they can be in the team.
Yeah, because they just don't have time to balance the two.
People don't have time to balance the two.
It's just very exhausting.
It is.
Someone that like, like, dappled a little before streaming.
In like, the Overwatch scene.
Uh, Pilgrim, thank you for the five kip that's so.
Thank you, thank you.
Well like, usually...
Usually you're not allowed to stream like scrims and stuff.
Or like, it's not a good like, streaming.
I personally don't think like, streaming...
Because it's a good streaming experience.
Just because you have to mute comms and everything.
And then, oh yeah, esports salaries have apparently been going down more and more.
Because like, back then, esports salaries are like, were so good.
Uh, because, uh, people didn't know.
Because people...
Esports was a new thing.
So people were like, just throwing money everywhere.
I mean, literally...
Literally, Overwatch League teams were owned by billionaires.
Who own, uh, were owned by billionaires.
Who own, uh, baseball and basketball teams.
And football teams too.
Because they didn't know where things were gonna go.
So exhausting that XQC was actually a pro player and quit to watch Dora the Explorer, whatever else he's doing.
Yeah, but one, the amount of stuff he's watched.
From, like, the amount of money.
I bet you, watching that one episode of Dora the Explorer, basically made him the same, The same salary as an entire year in Overwatch League.
I do it, I do it with him.
No, it's true.
There's some death contracts out there.
You see, like, you know how, like, there's, like, some game, some orgs where, like, one loss and you're instantly replaced.
Or something, or your roster gets dropped.
Because they want, it's, it's true though.
Because they want a team, they don't want to waste money, so they just, like, cut you out.
It's just incredibly stressful in general.
Oh, this is a stacked lobby.
This is a stacked lobby.
We have no tank players.
I was like, yippee!
And I realized, wait, we have no tank players.
I hope one of these guys played tank.
Trying to lobby?
Yes, because pro player.
Pro player.
And he's duo'd with another pro.
I don't remember which one.
And then March is duo'd, too, with a pro player.
Thoughts?
Opinions?
Suggestions?
Ideas?
Bruce Banner?
White Hawk.
I don't want to get rid of Cap.
It's okay, Doki.
Yeah, that's what you said last time!
And then we lost!
You said that last time!
All right.
Okay, guys.
Do we have any tank players?
One added...
Guys, don't be shy!
Guys, one added...
Oh my god, now I'm his gift here!
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Guys, don't be shy, guys!
Guys, come on!
Don't be shy!
You know you want to play a tank, guys!
One at a time, everybody!
One at a time!
Oh man.
This is not looking idea.
Where's our 12th player?
Oh!
Clank mag and thing.
Two!
One!
Oh...
Okay.
Okay, thank god.
We have a support.
I got a little scared.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Oh, we did ban Psylocke.
That means it's time to fucking...
Make sure I know where the fucking Psylocke is!
Oh my god, I'm so scared of it.
Don't die, please.
Please.
Oh my god.
Please do not die.
You are alive somehow!
Oh my god!
He...
Oh...
What?
What?!
Okay, good luck, everybody.
Good luck.
Good luck, everyone.
I believe.
I'm like a little worried right now.
I know we are at Psylocke.
Come on.
Come on, we stack.
We stack.
Double to the rocket.
There it is.
I got lost.
Oh my god.
I have to use it.
That's unlucky.
He bursted it open.
All right.
Oh my hero!
Where's my Psylocke?
There he is.
Oh my...
Okay, that was pretty clutch.
You gotta admit.
That was actually insane.
My fucking hero.
I'm alive.
I don't know how.
But I live, bitch.
My eyes are so tired.
Nice.
We'd always weekend.
Oh my god, contem.
Thank you for 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I'm so tired, grandpa.
But like, not actually.
I have a...
I'm hitting my fourth win now.
I'm hitting my fourth win.
Okay.
It's fine.
Our team is okay.
Wait.
Please stop.
No!
Please.
Please stop.
Please!
I'll ask me.
Reload.
Okay, nice.
Jesus Christ.
This game is so intense only because I have to... No.
That's right!
I walked to the side!
I'm okay now.
We're fine.
Oh my god, go on!
Thank you for that!
I'm gonna die here!
We stack!
We keep each other alive!
Look at me!
No!
Oh my god!
We were so close!
We almost lived!
How did we die?
How did this happen to me?
Please stop!
Oh my god!
Please!
Get away from me, Marge!
Okay.
Alright.
Die!
How do I live?
There's no... Also, Pilgrim!
Thank you for that!
Give themselves!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you!
He's bad.
The reload.
Oh my god.
I'm so close to the getting... Okay.
It's fine.
I'm... Okay.
And ma... And then he's gonna be like, maximum pause!
I can feel it!
We stack!
Please!
Oh my god!
Good job!
Okay.
I'm okay.
That's good.
Watch me!
Maximum... Oh my god!
Thank god!
Please get rid of this!
Please!
Y'all rock it!
Oh it's over!
It's over!
Keep up the momentum!
Quantum!
Marco!
Thank you for gifting a tier 1 sub!
Thank you everybody for the level 10 hype train!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Guys!
Thank you for the support!
Everybody!
Thank you!
That's it!
I'm hitting my 4th win!
This is it!
I feel it!
I feel the 4th win!
You guys have all motivated me!
I feel it!
I
Oh my god, are you serious?
Oh my god, I did the hook jump in.
I just get maximum pause.
No matter where I go, it's always me.
Oh my god, I have to be in here.
I got worried.
I got so worried.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Oh my god, I'm missing my... goodbye.
Leave me alone!
Oh my god, I'm fucking...
It's fine.
I'm not fine.
This is where I die.
Don't kill me, please.
I don't want another death.
One, two, two, zero.
That's a rash.
Every time I look around, I get maximum pulse.
Seven Deadly Sins.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, you can't read this.
You can't order it.
Let me see what...
What this...
How to pronounce this.
Oh, it just means...
How do I pronounce this for the biddies?
Oh my god.
I'm trying to figure out the tight language.
Oh.
Hong Kong?
Chong Chong.
Oh, Chong Chong.
Thank you for the...
100 biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Hezimi.
Thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Marco, thank you for gifting a sub.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it.
What?
Wait, see.
I really fell that far.
What happened?
Pilgrim!
Thank you for the 20 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
Thank you, buddy, for the support.
Thank you, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
It's like I'm like...
Beans or something.
Wow.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it, everybody.
Thank you for, like, all the love.
It gave me my...
It's giving me my fourth win.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we're fine.
We're so healthy.
It's just unfor...
Oh my god.
It's just unfortunate because I am...
I'm getting hot.
Like, I'm eating every...
I don't know how, but I am eating every fucking...
I'm eating every fucking Iron Man and I don't know how that's possible for me.
Like...
Right now!
You fucker!
What do I do?
If
I go towards my team, they die.
So I have to...
Oh my god.
Like, fuck me.
They do have Psylocke ult.
Jesus Christ.
Guys.
Like...
What do I do?
I hate it!
Oh my god.
I do not know why he didn't do that.
Maximum pulse!
This is like a...
I'm reporting.
This is a hate crime.
This is actually a hate crime now.
Like...
Guys!
I fucking...
I can't play it!
I'm fucking up, I can't.
I can't.
My god, there's no outplayability!
There's no outplayability here!
Like, how do I outplay that?
How do I?
There's literally no outplayability.
Bro, there's no... I'm reporting.
There's no outplayability.
There's actually no outplayability here.
It's literally... they're just... fuck me.
It's just...
Oh my god, I think the only outplayability I can do is literally I have to land my freezes as much as I can.
Next time, I'm just... I'm just gonna go into my team.
I swear to god.
I'm just gonna go to my team.
If I'm... if I'm gonna... I swear to god.
If he does that again, I'm gonna do it.
I'm... I'm gonna do it.
I... I'm gonna do it.
I... I'm gonna bubble.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh my god!
What... what is this?
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm so...
I'm... I'm really just getting fucking bullied.
I need two feet... from two miles away.
I need...
Holy shit, I can't live!
I can't fucking... Okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
The one time he stopped looking at me, I think... I... I'm swapping.
I can't.
There's literally no survivability here.
Oh my god, I can't swap.
There's nothing else to swap.
Fuck, they banned Loki.
I can't peek, bro.
I cannot peek.
This Ironman's doing whatever he wants.
I mean, bro, I... I'm shooting him as much as I can.
I'm not dead, then I'm fucking 1hp.
You people are like, fuck this.
There's nothing they banned Loki.
They banned my only escape.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
At least I got subs, though.
Wait, okay, this...
Guys, this is a joke.
This is a joke.
I deserve it.
Why was I supposed to use no playability?
It was never a shield for me.
I had to... I tried to go away from my team because he was still... I didn't want to... want the ult to kill everyone.
Dude, what you got?
I'm gonna use the bathtub right back.
Look, I'm thinking of the 5k if it's so sick and thank you.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
Wait, is he here?
That's right, you deserve that.
If I get banned, don't worry, I have connections.
I'll get unbanned.
You can't stop me.
That's crazy.
Um, Eddie, thank you for gifting us up.
Thank you.
That's right.
No, okay.
At first I was like, is he targeting me?
No, maybe I'm just out of position.
But then he fucking went straight to my face.
Everyone watched.
No one shot him.
And I still die.
And then that's when I knew it was a hate crime.
That's when I knew.
That's right.
Quantum, thank you for gifting a sub to Rigsy and March.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah, after the third one.
This is why there's no more support players.
This is why.
This is why no, no support players want to play anymore.
Now ban him.
No, I'll farm.
I'll farm his viewers because I know he's watching my stream.
By the way, check me out on Twitch, slash DokiBird, my stream.
Check me out.
So smart.
I'm gonna fucking avoid the rank one, the peak rank one leaderboard guy.
There's enough ELO terrorists.
In this world.
Why the fuck would I use it on the peak rank one guy?
They can add me.
Who's this guy?
Jeff's wiener?
Don't think because you have a clever name, I'll add you.
Jeff.
Are we cute?
Oh, we are cute.
Oh yeah, it's like 3 in the fucking morning.
The queues are so long.
At this time.
No!
I'm 885 now.
Sag.
Look, it's like 3 in the morning.
I've been playing Ravel since the XQC tournament.
And like...
My brain has devolved into like...
Like...
A fucking pre-present little boy in middle school.
Like anything is funny to me now.
Oh yeah, where was that that hulk?
No, you know what?
I'm gonna report the hulk too.
That reminds me.
...
See?
Oh there...
He joined in.
...
After his...
The hulk too.
No, that was also... Like, he wasn't part of the problem until the second half.
After the second half, when he, like, solo ulted me, he turned on his...
When he solo ulted me, like, three times.
I almost forgot about that.
I was too busy fucking crashing out on the first part.
It was an accomplice.
I can't believe this.
I do it all the time in Overwatch, and I never got banned.
On stream!
On stream, I did it every...
Okay, when I say all the time in Overwatch, I meant, like, once every couple of months.
Once or twice every couple of months.
Where, you know...
You know when you're, like, really mad?
And you gotta let out some steam, and you just start, like, reporting a person?
For, like, a thing they did to you?
But it was not, like, you know, legit?
Like...
You know?
Like, they're not hacking or anything.
Or they don't say any slurs.
But, like, you know, they did something to you.
And you just gotta, you know, you just gotta do a little report.
You just gotta do a...
A little report.
Yeah, and then, you know, it's, like, the little joys in life.
Wait, I should claim this.
They gave me Adam?
They just automatically gave me...
Oh my god!
They automatically just gave me Adam because I never picked!
I'm so fucking stupid!
Oh yeah, I should open this.
Yay!
I completed phase two!
And all I got was 20 tokens.
How do you do this?
Oh, okay.
Wait, did I not finish it?
What's that to do?
Upvote six allies in a quick match.
Land 30 final hits.
Complete six matches.
Defeat 50 enemies.
Wait.
Did I not do it?
I completed it.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay, now it's act three.
No, I completed this.
This is done.
So now it's this time.
Now I gotta wait.
What the fuck?
Where did...
How did my thing jump request?
Oh, there's...
There's a marsh...
Wait, how are you...
Celestial too?
Oh, no wonder you were crying.
Oh, and you hit your profile.
No...
Don't keep...
Don't do him like that.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I was wondering what he meant by that.
When he was like...
I really fell that far.
Like, I was like, what do you mean?
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
You're in my elo.
How does that feel?
Oh my god, these keys are long.
Oh.
Alright.
Is it a doom match?
It's taking 10 minutes?
I haven't been in a 10 minute queue in so long.
Oh, it's 3 in the morning.
Can you pass the trial of your soul?
Alright, are they role-playing?
There you go.
No role-play for you.
Oh, I'll role-play with you.
Whoa, hey guys.
You didn't see what I... Hey ladies.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
I just wanted to talk to the ladies.
I don't believe the role- I was trying to talk to the ladies!
This is why I can't have female friends.
Where are the ladies?
Hello ladies.
I would like to have more female friends.
Is this how females interact?
Hello.
Hello, my fellow female friends.
The game didn't die.
Hey me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, they're all healing themselves.
What am I?
How do you do, fellow females?
I'm really bad at interacting with women.
I'm so relatable.
Oh yeah, for those who didn't know, I had a talk with...
Everyone about how...
I don't really have a lot of female friends.
I've... I like...
Because like...
I was talking about how like...
It's just easier to handle male friends than it is female friends.
Because like...
I have a lot of like...
Solo female friends, but not like female group friends, really.
It's just... I...
From personal experience?
It's like...
I had a lot of negative experience with like...
Groups of women.
And like...
There was just less drama...
With like...
Male friends...
Than...
Female friends.
So it's like...
It's easier...
It was just easier to hang out.
No, it's just...
It's just like a mental warfare sometimes.
Because it's like...
I've had moments where like...
They...
Like you know...
Like one of my ex group of...
Female friends...
Who I'm not friends with anymore...
In high...
It was like...
High school.
This was high school.
Okay, I'll tell you the story.
This was a high school experience I had.
It was fucking terrible.
Um...
It was like an online group of female friends.
And it was a group.
And then...
So...
Um...
They like...
They would gossip about each other.
And then like...
Talk shit about each other.
But then like...
To like other...
You know....
Like others...
And then like...
But then like to them...
They would be like...
Buddy, buddy...
Yaaay.
And then like...
And then so it was like... such a... it was such like... it's just too much to handle.
Yeah, it was just incredibly two-faced.
And I had like multiple experiences like that.
Dude, it wasn't like, oh it happened once, and then like, oh I'd never again.
But it was like... um, it happened multiple times for me.
And then so that... I have like... that's why I only have like... singular female friends.
Like not like a group of female friends.
Other than sloppy sisters, they're fun.
But also like, they were like three different friends that I had that I brought together in a collab.
Um...
Uh... and like... uh...
But it was like, it was just such a backstabby environment.
I mean I have like... for male friends, I have a lot of male friends.
But like a lot of them are also like singular male friends.
They're not like a group of male friends.
And it's like... uh...
Uh... I had less drama involved.
And it was just cause I... all I do is just game.
That's it.
I just... it's just game.
And we talk about like...
Like... the drama I hear is not like...
as mentally draining as the drama I deal with.
I just want a game.
That's it.
I just...
I just want to play video games and chill.
I don't want to deal with drama.
I have...
I just...
I'm too stressed out.
I'm not...
I'm too...
Like...
The most I hear about like...
male...
Like when my...
When I had like a male group of friends...
Um...
From like...
What was it?
I guess like when I did Gmod and stuff was just like...
Relationship drama.
And like...
That shit...
I'm like...
Alright, whatever.
But like...
Oh my god.
It was so mentally draining.
And then like...
Okay...
My...
The worst experience I ever had...
Was that...
Um...
Oh my god.
Bro, okay.
This is so fucked up.
But this is like...
Me in high school?
This is from high school.
And...
What happened...
Was that...
Uh...
What happened was that...
Um...
I...
I didn't like how one person...
Was...
Uh...
How do I explain it?
I didn't like how...
Uh...
They were...
Talking back...
At people.
And then I told them I didn't like it.
And I said like...
Oh...
Um...
I...
Oh my gosh.
I'm trying to remember what happened.
Because this was like so...
It was high school.
And this is...
It was like incredibly two-faced.
And I told her that.
And then...
Um...
And I told her like...
I don't like how you treat people like this.
Et cetera, et cetera.
And then...
This is like online.
And...
Uh...
And it was like a group of artist friends too.
And...
I was like...
Oh, I don't like how you talk about this...
About others.
And...
Uh...
And I also...
Don't like that you do this sometimes.
And then...
What she did, she like got in touch with my IRL best friend and then told her that like I was a bitch and I said blah, blah, blah, blah about her and that like and then made some shit up and then my IRL best friend believed her and like and like she contacted my IRL best friend.
I was like, what the fuck?!
And like she like got our whole group friend, like the group we had to like go against me because it was like whoever says first and stuff, no like obviously I didn't sell that shit.
And then like, like okay, and then so like she got told she made up some fucking lies or some shit to like the group of friends that we share and then they obviously, they said all like they believed her and then they all like they all like, and then one of them who has access to one of my,
I gave her access to like one of my PlayStation accounts back then.
Like, uh, psn-Network account.
So she knew that password for it.
I was stupid and...
I did oh my god we had triple support ahaha I was dumb and um I was dumb and like didn't...and didn't uh change my twitter password for it I didn't, uh I didn't change my twitter password and share the same password as my twitter password.
And then she used that.
And like this was like It's like one of our mutual friends that did it, by the way.
It wasn't that bitch that did it that reached out to my best friend.
And then...
And then the mutual...
A mutual...
Like, fucking hacked into my Twitter account, and then tweeted some really fucked up shit?
And then said like really fucked up shit about me?
Like, on the Twitter account, pretending to be me.
And like, not pretending to be me, but be like.
Oh Doki Bade Blah Blah Blah Blah Blah Blah Wah Wah Wah Doki Bade, and I was like W hАt THE FUck?
Like I was like.
Holy fuck!
And like this was not my only bad experience, too.
Like that was not my only bad experience with ...
Like, a group of people.
What's wrong with him?
Okay.
Yeah, so, like, I'm a little traumatized about that.
I'm a little traumatized with that shit, guys.
What the fuck is going on?
Alright, I should focus up.
Oh my god!
Everyone just died!
Yeah, I have, like, two or three more experiences with different groups.
So now I just have, I don't have groups of friends.
I have, like, I don't do groups of friends anymore.
You understand why, right?
I have...
I don't have groups of friends anymore.
I have... I have singular friends.
No, no, we're not... No, and then she became best friends with that other... with that girl.
Oh my god, Lupa, what are you doing?
Doesn't matter.
Shit, it's fine there.
Oh.
Oh, no.
What the fuck?
I'm trying...
Yeah, and then she, like, became best friends with her.
It's cause, like, okay, so, like, what she did... was that I had, like, a... private...
um, vent Tumblr account back then.
And, um, and, like, she... I was venting about something that was unrelated to my IRL best friend.
And then, like, she, like, took that screenshot and, like, told my IRL best friend that it was about her.
That's what she did.
I think we can see you all at first, and then we can save, uh, Mantis for last.
Oh, that, yeah, like, that's traumatized shit, right?
That's fucking crazy shit, right?
Like, like, what the fuck?
Cause, obviously, like...
I'm trying not to do something crazy right now.
I know they have...
Oh, okay.
Cool.
Okay,
nice.
Nice, I got him.
Oh my god.
Alright, nice.
Alright, so that's why.
I just, like, my lesson for myself that day was that I just, just have, like, I have, like, singular friends, not, like, friend groups anywhere after that.
That's why I also have, like, insane trust issues, too.
Cause, like, like, you'd think, like, I've only, that happened to me, like, once.
But, like, the worst part is that this happened to me, like, at least two more times.
From, like, different groups of friends.
And they've all been, like, equally traumatizing.
Oh my god, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
You're fucking kidding me for all love.
I'm not getting from love.
I have no supports.
Oh my god.
I literally couldn't press Q.
That's Ashley, fuck.
Skelectus ulted nothing, bro.
She ulted nothing.
She's 1-H plan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're TPing, we're TPing.
Oh.
I realize we're TPing.
Hey, maybe we should wait until we're all ready.
Yeah, I'm waiting, I'm waiting, I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
Wait till we're all ready.
Alright, alright.
I'm doing a bug, ready?
Three, two, one, above a bug.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I remember you on the right one.
Okay.
There we go, that was worth it.
That was fucking worth it.
I literally killed two from that.
That was so worth it.
I literally clutched for that.
The floor is... zero... two... zero...
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Yeah, I killed the Luna and also the Hawkeye with that look.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
You'll need a tough-notch team to win this one.
I...
Yeah, that's why, like, for me, I learned a lot from that type of experience.
I don't know.
I just... groups is, like...
There's just too much dynamics for me.
That's why I have a small... that's why you guys might notice I have a very small group of friends.
And majority of it is just, like, like, two to three.
Like, I don't have, like, big groups of friends.
Cause it's just... or, like, one.
I like one-to-one interactions.
More than, uh...
More than, like, group interactions in general.
I see this great sadness in you.
Like, that's just, like, my personal experience.
Cause one-to-one interactions, that's why I have, like, a small group of friends.
Or, like, a small circle of... I won't say groups.
Or, like, more can... more, like, a smaller circle of friends.
Just cause, like...
I like keeping, like, a tighter...
Like, tighter...
Um...
What?
Like, a tighter circle...
A circle of friends that I trust.
Oh, hold on.
Okay, I should focus.
Well, hello.
Every time...
Uh...
Cannot play DPS.
Like...
He struggles.
He's actually a really...
He's really, really good at...
Non...
Non-tanks.
Oh, that was a...
That's crazy.
We're down one.
I'm trying to heal.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
I'm...
I'm more about, like...
More about, like...
Uh...
Oh, what the fuck?
That's the real one.
Yeah, I have, like, acquaintances...
Like...
People...
Uh...
Colleagues...
And, like, you know...
Yeah.
No, we are definitely not top 500.
I think I need, like, one, two to three more games.
Yeah!
I don't know what the fuck that game was.
That game was so weird.
Windows is a tank player.
So, I don't know why he was on Iron Man.
I have no idea.
Oh, that's funny.
I did not do a lot of damage.
I was not doing damage.
As Mantis...
My...
My Luna and Invis...
To be fair, I was distracted too.
I was like, we have two supports.
We're running triple supports.
I don't need to heal as much.
I...
I don't need to do as much, guys.
I have triple support.
It's literally having a conversation.
Like...
It's fine.
Three...
The other two can pick up the slack.
They...
They can...
They can do the rest for me.
Alright.
It's time for our...
RPs.
I love roleplay.
When will we have our custom roleplay lobbies?
Just like in...
In Overwatch.
Where are my roleplayers?
Oh my god.
Is this a...
I didn't queue up dude.
Oh wait, there it is.
Hello, my roleplayers.
Hello, my fellow roleplayers.
Hello.
Hello, how do you do, fellow RPrs.
You know like in Overwatch.
What the...
What did I do wrong?
No.
He's not a roleplayer.
Somebody stop him.
I can't believe it.
Shit!
I can't believe they would do such a thing!
Hello everybody, I'm still roleplaying.
Okay, anyway, as I was saying, in Overwatch custom lobbies... Okay, get rid of this guy.
This guy is not a roleplayer.
We gotta leave.
Get him out.
Like, are you stupid?
I'm so... No.
Don't do this to me.
I try to defend us.
I try to defend us from... From... From the guy ruining our RP.
Yeah!
What was I saying?
Oh yeah, in Overwatch custom lobbies... They have a feature where... Oh my gosh.
They have a feature where you can make custom lobbies, yeah?
And then... There's like a... Sometimes I like, check what they have.
And they have this thing called Tinder Watch.
Where like, people... People actually try to... Find their significant other... Via Overwatch.
And it's actually... It's actually... Real... Dating... Like a real dating lobby.
Not Tinder Watch.
Stop calling me.
Yeah.
No, I told you guys about this before.
No, it's crazy.
I still think it's fucking funny.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
As someone who plays Overwatch, I never marry someone who plays Overwatch.
Oh, it's this Twitch guy.
Um... Everyone's over fantastic.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
Show me your fantastic dude.
No.
That's awkward.
Wow!
Mm.
That's awkward, guys... on the enhymean torch.
Hey, you can... You can vouch for me, right?
Like... Like I deserve the fantastic here, right?
You're in this game of Latin?
Not... Not this season.
Last season?
Yeah.
Not this season.
I've been... I've been playing less this season.
No idea.
Alright, man.
I'm still getting it now.
Still getting it?
Well, something's a bit kinky.
Except today.
Today I just... Today I just like... I got... I don't know.
I just feel like it.
I just felt like rivals today.
I just feel extra rival-y.
Guys, do we have a tank player?
Yeah.
Surely we have a tank player, right?
For all these Mr. Fantastics?
Surely...
No, I didn't ban him.
I didn't ban him.
The group guy.
It was the same group guy.
Surely... Can I have my Fantastica?
Like, actually, I am on one trick.
Please let me have my Fantastica.
But if he's actually on one trick as well.
But are you both on tics?
But I'm like, unwashing.
Like, I need it.
Like, I'm slursing at the helo.
Please let me have my...
Oh my god.
This is actually tragic.
I've never seen the Fantastica.
Does anyone have a tank?
Does anyone have... Can anyone play tank?
Oh my god.
This is so sad.
We have a tool of a guy banking his heart out.
This dude, he's GM, too.
Oh my god.
Why are you one tricking at 3.30 in the morning?
No, this is East Coast server.
Why are you one tricking at 6 AM in the morning?
He's dead in voice.
You shouldn't have tried typing.
And it's like, not even like, you know, uh... Not even like, a good one trick, too.
Oh, he went... He went into... Diamond form.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, that is not fine.
That's true.
That's not fine anymore.
I think he's gonna die.
Guys, we need a Loki.
We need a Loki.
Do we?
Like, like... Oh, you got fun.
Yes.
Because we're all grouped together.
Loki will fuck.
He just...
And then he heals.
Well, I have shit, though.
Yeah, shit.
Hello?
Oh my god.
I won't disappear so easily.
Um, that's actually not the cooldown.
Oh my god.
Shush GM players.
Bro, bro, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
Were you doing, uh...
What was it?
I know Japan.
Were you...
Watching...
Were you, uh, watching the...
JP...
Street Fighter tournament?
Yeah, EVO Japan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my...
Um...
Games have...
Game...
This game...
I'll just say...
It's...
It's just this game.
Oh my god.
I...
Okay.
I know games might look rough right now.
But like, literally, it's just this game.
We...
We had...
Three...
Zero take players.
And...
Two...
Mr. Fantastic one tricks.
Which is crazy.
Cause like...
In what world...
Do we have two...
Mr. Fantastic one tricks?
Like...
I mean...
In this one.
I like...
Like...
The highest one in the game.
But...
It's Celestial 2.
I'm Celestial 1.
Thanks so much.
There you go.
It's just an hour.
I don't even know.
I'm...
I'm only...
I mean...
Don't worry.
I just have a focus.
Oh yeah.
I came from YouTube where I streamed 12 hours.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
This is...
Yo what the fuck are we doing really?
You're just seeing a choke and nothing's alright.
This is a little awkward.
Oh my god.
This is very awkward.
This is real firepower.
Anyway, we have nothing to force ult so I'm literally useless.
Did you just say you might be the worst Mr. Fantastic player?
Like...
How would the other Mr. I'm going here.
Oh my god.
You're Mr. Fantastic.
Here they are now.
Alright.
Goodbye Brawl Pro.
That was a roll.
Yeah.
They're...
They're comparing rank as if it's like...
We have a piece of problems.
Who uses ult first?
I don't know.
That...
That is awkward.
I didn't think he was gonna...
Oh my god.
Please, Luna.
Please.
Yeah.
This was actually a GG on, uh...
I got the rocket on the Punisher.
GG on character select, unfortunately.
I'm on the low key.
Don't have good the low key.
Don't worry, Rigsy.
I got you.
Just gonna kill you.
Oh my god.
We have to play more.
Aw mercy, I told you we're on DPS or we won't lose it.
I'm such a silly boy...
Oh my god!
We have to play more.
We...
Changed.
Oh my god.
Oh!
How?
Please tell me someone's on Strange.
Oh!
The current score is...
Thank God.
Thank God, guys.
Alright, so I have to...
Time to avoid both...
Mr. Fantastic players.
Alright, let's go.
We can avoid both...
Mr. Fantastic players.
Let's go!
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I'm solo tanking now.
I think it's just...
Awkward when...
I think it's not awkward.
Please...
Oh...
So...
I play Luna, but like, I'm not the greatest Luna.
Oh, he hides!
He's like not even...
How are you a fucking one trick man?
You don't play...
I was rank 151 tricking, okay?
Just let me play my hero.
I was rank...
Dude, I can't control that, brother.
I was rank 150...
What, in the beginning of the season?
Like...
I just...
I'm just wondering, like...
Is that even...
Okay, okay.
People who are like...
Not even...
Like...
I have a command where I tell what my peak rank is.
But like...
You don't understand.
In the beginning of the season, it's so easy to get high peaks.
Because like...
I'm just good at my character, okay?
It is...
Like...
People who put on the stream title...
Be like...
Um...
I'm trying to...
I would jump alone like...
Come on.
Peak 100, or something.
Like...
It's impressive...
It was like...
Top 10.
But if it's like...
Peak 100, or peak...
200, or something on their stream title...
It's not that impressive when you see like...
What...
At what...
Uh...
When they got it.
I'm just coming in with that?
I'm just coming in.
I'm not coming in.
Okay...
That's my personal...
Okay guys.
It's not as impressive.
It's like people who like brag about... I was 150.
I'm like, when in the season were you?
I need to know.
Like beginning at... Oh my god!
I'm still alive, he didn't hit anything.
Okay, I'm not alive anymore.
Alright.
I am pushing him away from me.
I'm gonna push him away from me.
Oh my god.
Let's go next round.
This is the first fucking game.
Holy shit.
That...
Doki Bird.
That was interesting.
Why does it suddenly say Doki Bird?
Out of nowhere.
Amplifier will save us.
Yeah, it sort of did it.
Oh my god!
Minus 24 just because I was in a GM game!
The mount... Minus 24 just because I was in a GM game.
I...
Oh my... Wait.
Did you avoid...
Boat Fantastics?
Okay, nice.
Yes!
Of fucking course!
Alright, that's good.
That was a fast avoid.
Awkward.
That was awkward.
Actually.
Okay.
I need to know.
Actually.
Alright.
If he actually...
If he actually got there, like...
Alright.
Where is it?
He has a GM tag.
You see that?
Alright.
Okay.
I know he didn't end Top 500 in any season.
Because...
Actually.
No.
Because...
Rixx has that one.
But...
Didn't Rixx end Top 500 last season?
Oh no!
He didn't!
He barely...
He just...
Okay.
So like...
If he ended recently...
He would put the...
Last season...
He would put the Top 500 season.
So...
Uh...
So like...
He didn't.
So I knew that...
Oh yeah.
You're right.
I could've...
He didn't.
So I knew that...
He didn't end Top 500.
Okay.
What about his?
His...
What's...
Oh.
I'm still...
I'm still high bro.
We're both...
Celestial.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
His entire purpose in life was to play the worst characters possible.
That was...
That was his purpose.
He made it to Celestial.
30...
271...
51 hours already.
Jesus fuck.
Bro.
What the fuck?
This guy has like...
30 more...
This guy has almost 40 more hours than me and he's still in Celestial 3.
Bro.
The fact that he has like...
Almost 30...
Yeah.
No.
He has 30 hours more than me and he's still in Celestial 3.
Which was fantastic.
I mean he was really good.
In the beginning of Season 2.
Ew.
Don't say that.
I played League for 10 years and I'm still...
I'm still a gold Sag.
It's okay.
It's different.
That's different guys.
Wait.
Someone is...
Someone on the enemy team is top 500.
I don't know who.
Twitch TV.
Oh, we have 3 supports.
We have 3 supports.
Glad you remembered.
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna fucking know her.
It's worse because you played League.
Are you followed?
Are you subbed?
Are you gonna be there tomorrow on the live?
No.
I'm fucking...
I'm playing a tournament tomorrow.
Okay.
That's a good excuse.
That's true.
The fact that you're able to still play it for 10 years...
After that?
Garrett, if we win this game, how about that?
Well, if we lose, it's not gonna be on me.
Think so?
Good, alright.
That's good, he can't commit more hate crime.
Alright, what are we... I'm not being proud of this vote.
Aww...
I've got terrible doggy players on the team.
I'm not judging.
Mantis, do you play, uh...
Do you play like Sue or Luna or something?
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the battle.
We should triple tank, honestly.
No, we just play wolf.
Yeah, I play wolf, yeah.
Fifteen!
You think I've only played 13 hours?
Joke's on you.
Shit doesn't work out.
Let's go up right quick.
I would just start on mag, bro.
They're gonna have wolf, probably, if Groot's in the game.
That was just so bad.
Aw, I'm very fine.
That was not bad.
Yeah, he's pretty bad.
Yeah, pretty good.
I wish he was good, because...
If he was good, then the game would have some diverse impumps.
What the fuck?
Same match.
Do remember to call me Logan.
Why would I do that, bub?
I am one of the few who can throw the both of you.
What?
What tournament is tomorrow?
Uh, it's called the North America...
Like, it's literally...
It's so cringe.
It's called the High Elo Player Tournament or something.
I'm...
I'm playing with Mace.
I don't know.
Some weird ass shit.
I'll be honest.
Mace is a fucking terrorist, bro.
That guy's baby rage is so hard.
He's funny as fuck though.
I believe it.
Most of his rage.
I honestly think he...
He's just a rage baiter.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Oh my god.
Maybe I don't got you.
You just can't put it.
I was worried.
I was out behind you.
No total.
Alright, well...
My shield is gone so good luck Luna.
Can't heal right now.
Luna please.
I'm going my best to heal you.
Oh my god.
Come on bro, this app Geoff shit is so annoying.
I'll do UL first.
That's awkward!
Oh my god, it's my favorite, guys!
Oh, nice!
It is my favorite.
Wait, wait, this is my favorite.
Wait a minute.
Wait, this is my favorite, guys!
We got...
Yay!
Nice.
Jesus, they've been fucking stalling this for 20 years!
I have to use this.
I was too scared.
I was actually so scared.
Oh, wow.
Oh my god.
How is this still going?
Captain, captain.
I don't know.
Okay.
Fuck off.
It's fine.
I'm gonna play high ground so I can get out.
Oh my god, wait, she did it!
Oh, she did not do it!
That's one though.
This is bad.
This is a little bad.
I have to keep this because I got scared.
I'll bubble for you, Wolverine.
Scare your suit.
I just got so long, Pip.
Okay.
That's good.
Oh my god.
I have to focus so much because there's dive!
Please, please.
No!
I can't jump high enough.
It's clear, I'm still needed here.
I tried to jump, but he jumped off!
He jumped off!
Oh, that's unlucky.
I can get a Michael.
At least a while.
Come on, Michael, come on, Michael.
He's trying to go hard.
Jesus Christ.
Which one's mine?
She's mine!
Oh my god, that was so scary.
That was so scary.
I was 1 HP.
It's okay, I will pass now.
That was so scary.
Help my Luna!
Oh but...
I don't feel so fine.
I don't feel so fine no more.
It's not fine anymore.
I don't feel fine.
I don't feel fine anymore.
I killed like all of them.
Oh my god.
No!
In fact, it was not fine.
Guys, it was not fine.
It did not feel fine in the end.
You ready?
Do you want to just go hella, just sit in the back and just two-tap Jeff?
It was not very fantastic, guys.
I did not feel very fantastic today.
Hey, thank you for the hundred biddies!
Thank you, thank you!
I have a theme that fuck-ass theme song, huh?
It is or something.
It's a point out.
Alright.
It's time to go through hell yet again.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Snap!
Yay!
I am the queen of degen gaming hours.
It's not Marvel Rivals without being degenerates.
Alright, let me use this.
No lamp!
Oh!
No lamps, I guess.
I am the queen of degeny.
I am the queen!
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm just killing them very much.
Hey, make me as well tell them.
Yeah, this is a little awkward.
Oh, usually I don't.
I've just been.
I'm just gonna block my shots.
We're still fucking gaming.
I outnumber you.
Behold!
Your powers are mine!
Oh, at least.
Oh, nice.
It's still winable.
I killed Jeff.
You guys can win the fuck out of that.
There they are.
I am ready to put on a show.
Hold on, Lola.
Hold on.
What the fuck?
He ran in.
Okay.
Hey, okay.
Alright.
Goodbye.
I am
ready to put on a show.
That's fine.
We're fine, Thor.
You and me.
Okay.
He's ready to assemble, guys.
What?
Why me?
What the fuck?
That's fucked up.
That's...
Oh, and then the map moves, too.
What if we just have, like, clear match up or something?
You're on the back.
Oh, my god!
I don't have...
I don't...
Ah!
Oh, my god!
There's a...
There's a god!
I believe now!
Later, later.
Okay.
I believe now.
I believe...
I got solo ulted, like, two times in one round.
Round.
It was hard to believe in anything anymore.
Your powers are mine!
The reflex app...
That's pretty good.
Your powers are mine!
Okay.
Nine...
Eight...
Seven...
Six...
Five...
Four...
Eight...
Let's go.
Oh my god!
Twinsies!
Let's go.
I'll most likely be the one that dies!
Alright, I didn't mean to press shift there, but that's okay.
Alright.
That's awkward.
It's just you and I.
That's okay.
That is definitely very awkward for us.
Hey guys, I don't know how I'm alive.
Oh, what the fuck?
I couldn't count!
It's fine.
That's fine.
I lost track.
I would admit I lost track to counts.
I don't think anybody plays cap, guys.
Okay.
Reload.
I have to reload.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Really good tech.
Oh my god.
I got... I got scared.
I got scared.
I got so scared.
You ready?
I don't think that...
I'm gonna discard him instantly.
You ready?
He caught the mech.
No, he caught... What the fuck?
I shifted and he fucking ulted me!
That's crazy.
He actually shifted me!
Oh my god.
I shifted and he dragged me all the way out.
That was crazy.
I got solo ulted three times.
He like ulted me and it dragged my entire lamp.
He dragged my entire lamp into the ult.
That was actually insane.
Cause I tried...
Ooh.
Okay, but if I lose, I can climb back to Celestial too.
And that's the brush of it.
I've always been a...
I've always been a fucking tree hater.
I've always hated Groot.
Bro!
That was crazy!
I tried...
I...
I tried to give invuln to my cloak.
I tried to give invuln to my cloak and he literally...
He literally like ulted me out of it.
Fuck, he sucked.
There's nothing else I could do about it.
No!
No, I like Luna Snow.
She's my exception.
It's not true.
Oh, hey, there's Mace.
Oh, he's...
I know he's dealing with somebody, but I don't know who.
Who do you think you want to be today?
Hence, I want to try rank.
I want to avoid it.
Uh...
Rank is fun.
Just like...
It's just...
It just gets you super addicted.
The Groot Trauma.
Everyone's just like...
Get him out!
Everyone...
Everyone's like...
No more Groot!
I have had enough.
It's kind of fun.
I've been streaming Ravos for 15 hours now.
I don't know.
Ben Torch, Bantorch.
They're not gonna ban Torch.
Think so.
But they're gonna pick...
Cap Jeff Wilson.
That's a ship.
They have less, but they're not gonna ban Torch.
I think it's fun when you win.
Exactly!
That'll do.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
I mean, they do have a Torch player, so...
I'd rather fight Cap than Torch.
He's gonna be on a side lock though, so...
Watch out for that.
Alright.
Luna Rocket.
Uh...
I'll just put...
My orb on.
Awesome, Mr. Frisco!
Thank you for the tier 1 sub!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Um...
Yeah.
He's like the best tank.
In higher elo.
It's just really annoying.
In general.
He's just very annoying to play against.
Alright.
Time to get fucked by Captain America.
I died.
Woo!
I love higher elo.
I'm never coming anywhere to eat.
Donkey?
Alright.
For America.
Don't worry.
It'll happen to all of you too, one day.
One, three, two, one!
The enemy has arrived.
Yep, they have got...
and clock.
Oh, hey, hey, hey.
You remember what I said?
Hey, look at this over there!
Whoa!
Guys, remember what I just said?
No!
It's like I played this game.
It's too...
It's like I played this game at high elo then.
No.
No!
There it is!
There he is!
Up, he's coming over!
Bitch.
Okay.
Alright, spy.
Spy.
I told you.
Told you.
Oh my god, please.
No!
Oh my god, there was nothing I could do.
There was no outplayability there.
There was literally...
There was literally no outplayability to that.
I was just...
I was god.
It truly was...
It truly was like...
a TT moment of my life.
Oh, it's blessed.
There we go.
That's just like a Psylocke one...
A really good Psylocke one-trick.
So I...
Yeah.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Mmm...
If that...
I might just go...
Invis then.
Actually, no.
If I go...
That's why their...
Their Psylocke is not trying to...
Their Psylocke is not 1v1-ing our Psylocke because...
I hear her.
She said Sayonara.
But that's why, because...
Oh, nice!
Uh, because our Psylocke has the orb.
So like...
Which is a good advantage for us.
So like, he doesn't know what to do.
I heard Sayonara and I got scared.
Who put Siren first?
Let's get that.
Psylocke may be going for old.
Stuck, stuck, stuck, stuck.
Save me.
Oh my god!
I have to!
What?
That was that though.
Alright.
3...
2...
1...
3...
I should...
I don't know if I should have ulted that.
I thought we stacked together and we fine.
I didn't think our rocket would die.
That's just unfortunate for our rocket.
Yeah.
It was unfortunate.
I saved it because...
I saved it just because like, our rocket...
I didn't think we would die if we all stacked together.
I need to say Luna because...
Bless is gonna have a...
Pocket now.
With the...
Bless is gonna...
There's that...
Jesus Christ.
We're gonna have a...
Orb now, Snowflake, so he can use it.
No!
He's like right here!
Our rocket ignored me!
Rocket, why?
I thought we were friends!
See, this is what happens when you ignore the Hella!
Oh no.
I got no He- That's what happens!
Why are you ignore the Hella?
We died!
Nah, that hero's about to it.
I got no John's back.
Oh my god!
I'm okay!
No he walked away from me!
He walked away!
That's why I was like, why did he walk away from me?
Oh...
Where's Arihalla?
Nice.
Like, how did Arihalla kill people?
Uh, one Thai Asian bitch, yeah.
What?
Excuse me?
Oh my god, I don't... I don't trust this is sacking.
I don't trust this is sacking.
I...
I just... I couldn't trust this anymore.
I... I made a decision.
Where?
I'm sorry.
I couldn't trust.
I have trust issues.
I'm sorry.
Alright.
I have ult here.
I'm with you on the Psylocke.
Okay.
Psylocke still wants our back here.
They did.
Let's drop down, buddy.
Alright.
There's the Psylocke.
Nice.
I think they're gonna...
Oh, they went strange, yeah.
Okay, that's good.
Got scared there.
Get Mr. Businessman!
The current score is...
Zero!
I'm holding my breath that whole fight.
Alright.
I'm currently...
Celestial 2.
Which is like...
Where top 500 is at right now.
But it's like...
Middle of Celestial 2, where he's at.
I'm not in the middle, I'm at the bottom.
That's the one Lucky Games, but it's also at 4 in the morning.
So games are gonna be very rough at 4 in the morning.
It's like no...
It's almost like nobody's queuing at this time.
That's so weird.
The cry never stops, though.
Give me a water.
...to have an all-superhero band?
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready!
I people look forward to the...
Too bad I can't have you in my realm, little king.
I've faded back in time.
Yay!
DJ and our...
The battle starts in 5.
4...
3...
2...
1!
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright.
That's cool.
Alright, I'm ready.
Okay, I'm ready for real.
And iron.
Oh, they have iron?
What the fu- What the fu- What the fu- What
the fu- What happened?
Wait, isn't- Oh yeah, Mr. Big Moon.
Okay.
All prey has been located.
Yeah!
No, yeah, I did.
I-I-I get very-I got very deleted.
I'm trying to like- Oh my god, I can't use my clap anywhere cause nobody's looking at me.
Oh!
I think our team might be dead.
Ha-he!
Oh no.
This is bad.
Yeah, no.
We're dead.
We're dead!
This is...
A lot of damage!
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
starting to fight.
Alright, I'll wait.
I can wait.
I'm patient.
Where are are we...
How's-山 Continents.
Like, I...
I...
I can't...
Like just, there was nothing I could do.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Okay, we need to, like, dive together.
I'm down, call a target.
Oh, so Aura, thank you for the five, give the subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I hear him.
I knew it.
I knew you were around.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Um... I'm going back on her.
Just having to roll.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm alive.
Oh, my God.
I'll hit him all with that.
That's good.
What am I... Punch that fucker.
Oh, thank God.
I gotta take it to the real Hulk.
Okay.
We saw a mile up.
He's on top, yeah.
I promise you won't reach the way.
Watch me so.
Almost there.
Don't turn back now.
Nice.
They're stacking the work out of there.
I want the RNG.
I have to use that.
I... I could... I saw them.
I saw it in their eyes.
They wanted to do things.
They want...
If I did it all, I'd be dead.
I... I could see it.
Their eyes.
They want it.
They were bloodthirsty.
Alright.
He's going for it now.
Goodbye, everybody.
We were not stacking this.
We were not.
Oh my God.
I'll patch you up.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Someone scratch my back.
Someone killed their Luna nine times too.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Like, I can't do it.
Oh my God.
That's so much damage.
What the fuck was that no-reg though?
I hate it when you get no-reg though sometimes.
I hear somebody.
I hear him.
I'm not crazy.
You're halfway there.
Keep going.
I hear him.
I know.
Okay.
I have to make sure.
Please, please, please look.
You're welcome, welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
My God.
Don't let me die.
Oh my God.
Oh.
Come out.
Please stack, please stack, please stack, please stack, please stack, no!
Oh no, one last fight!
They used both support ults.
They used Salak ults.
They used everything.
Oh my god, they banned Loki.
They fucking banned Loki.
Yeah, it's fine.
You know these good ults.
Probably have Lola, no?
No, no, they use it really easy.
Salak?
Okay.
Oh, that's unlucky.
No, there's a Namor behind us!
That's so unlucky.
I got it hurt by Namor.
Just gonna do that for my team.
Okay.
Oh my god, we won that!
Get the whole way!
One, two, two, one.
Oh!
No, of course they have...
No, they have to ban Loki.
Because Loki is such a good counter against Salak.
Another epic victory!
Thank god.
The other support died more than me.
I suffered so much.
I had to suffer so much.
Thank god.
That was...
That was twitchy.
Still got the W though.
Uh, Woodbird!
Thank you for that Twitch Prime!
Uh...
Ooppy!
Thank you for Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you!
Taylor!
Thank you for gifting a sub!
To Slavia!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, yay!
Rewards!
Plus 18.
It's because I didn't do that well.
I was getting, like, hard focused by Scylocke.
Wait, I get it.
I know what to do.
My C plus.
My record is, like, all over the place.
I know what to do.
What's your...
God dammit!
Okay, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna remember this.
Okay, level 64.
Alright, I remembered.
If I see that, I don't wanna play against Scylocke.
Like, I...
There we go.
Level 64.
Okay, guys.
Remind me that...
When we get in game...
If we see level 64...
They might change banners.
So, like, I don't trust, like, banners anymore.
But level 64...
No, my duo is not a Scylocke main.
He is...
A Starlord player.
But also, like...
Triple...
Starlord got nerfed.
And Triple Support got nerfed, too.
But he can play other stuff.
I believe.
Wait, they missed...
Mace got off?
One game and you got off, Mace?
Oh, two games and...
Oh!
Yeah, I get off, too.
Minus 26.
Jesus.
Yeah, I get off as well, guys.
Minus...
No, I...
I'd also...
I'd be mad, too.
Don't worry.
Minus 26.
Wait, what is it?
Was it actually?
Plus 16.
Oh, yeah!
Plus 15 and plus 16.
Damn.
That's actual hell.
I mean, it is a lot harder.
Like, the higher yen.
Because you'll gain so little.
Because there's not enough people playing in the lower trenches.
No, it's not...
That one wasn't performance-based elo.
It's more so, like, he was placed in lower celestial lobbies.
And because he's placed in lower celestial lobbies, you don't gain as much if you're in the higher celestial one lobby.
I mean, I can look at...
Jesus.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this was a GM game.
Oh, my God.
That's rough, buddy.
That's fucking rough, buddy.
Yeah, so, this was our...
This was the GM game.
I got minus 24, but he got minus 27.
Because, uh...
He was playing in, uh...
Because he was celestial one.
Yeah, higher loss.
Technically, you're supposed to carry your team.
It's alright.
It went alright.
I had fun.
Yeah.
Yeah, I have a lot of coins, but there's no...
Not really anything I wanna buy.
I wouldn't buy the Luna skin if it wasn't a battle pass.
We have to pay real money for that.
Hahaha.
Hello, roleplayers.
I am here to hang out.
Hello, women.
And Loki.
Woah, what the fuck?
Level 64.
Which hero do you think you wanna be today?
Okay.
There's no...
Level 64.
That to worry about.
Oh, you're right.
Loki is also sometimes a woman.
You're right.
Just really wanna play Viz.
I low-key wanna play...
In Viz right now.
Alright.
Wait, it's 4.
Okay.
6, 7, 8, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 8, 9, 12, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
That's 13 hours of sleep before my next stream.
We wanna buy a cap roll.
Yeah, we can do it with this though.
Why are you playing Viz or Luna when I feel like I wanna Viz?
Well, the meta...
Or Luna?
It just depends how I feel.
Um...
Okay, meta supports currently from what I was told.
It's...
Loki...
In Viz...
Luna.
Rocket is like okay, but like...
She's not like...
He's not like actually a good, good pick.
Uh...
Cause it's so easy to destroy.
It's so...
I feel like In Viz...
Can you play Luna?
Number 12.
A low key Luna...
Cloak and Dagger is garbage.
In higher elo.
She's only good in low elo.
Oh, okay, I guess not.
Okay...
I guess...
I guess not.
Um...
Might need no support here.
Says DPS Black Panther.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
We might need another support here.
When it's the fucking...
When it's the fucking Black Panther.
There.
No, we have to support.
She's fine.
I love it.
We're three versus our dive.
Four...
Three...
Two...
One...
All you need to do is capture...
You better be stacked.
Yeah, Widow.
This is Pearl?
Oh, this might be Pearl.
She's not bad.
I'm gonna have a good day.
All right.
He gets Razzler.
I'm lucky.
I'm going Widow.
Oh my god, everyone.
I'm trying my best!
But there's also a Widow and I don't wanna get sniped!
Oh nice, I don't wanna get sniped now.
Hee hee.
Hello, though.
Yay!
Oh, they're running...
Rocket, Mantis?
That's not enough heals.
All right.
Let's go!
I think the...
Rocket is closer, I guess.
Okay, Rocket else first.
Rocket literally has his...
He has...
He's at like...
Double my rings.
Like who should...
Who all first?
I'm not even close right now.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh yeah, that's what I'd like to see.
They're stuck.
Matt, this is only good if like...
Oh, it's one of the...
I'm about to ult F4 and go to bed.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's the...
RIGSI!
What the fuck?
Wait...
Why did RIGSI get this random like...
Straight hate?
Out of nowhere.
He's just like...
Fight away!
Fuck you, RIGSI!
I like...
It was just out of nowhere.
It was just like...
Fuck my team.
And also...
Especially you, RIGSI!
That was so fucking random.
Awesome, Rocket!
Thank you for the...
Oh wait, thank you to your one sub!
Thank you!
That's so silly.
Like, out of nowhere.
He just really fucking hated one person in particular.
Oh, he's not gonna...
Hello.
I shall slowly push this cart.
You'll never know.
I shall leave now.
Nice!
Oh, I couldn't predict that.
I'm lucky.
I still understand the random...
Fuck you though.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Oh no.
Nice.
Oh, I didn't see him.
I'm not landing my ices right now.
I think it's because of the time.
I'm helping you.
Thank you.
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm not landing anything.
I...
Any of my ices right now.
That's not good.
Yeah.
You're magical.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
Please!
Oh...
Okay.
I need to, like, focus up on my freezes.
I'm not landing my luna freezes right now.
Which is not good.
I'm also, like, getting absolutely dove on right now.
Get that vehicle moving again!
This dive is not fun.
No, it's not normal.
It is not normal.
I'm not...
I'm just...
Particularly enjoying Ravos.
20 times!
I'm going low-key.
That's it.
Oh wait, I can't.
I was gonna go low-key.
I was done.
I was done!
Wait, wait.
Mr. Funt1.
I suppose that helps.
Jesus Christ.
There's no way.
I was gonna say, there's no way I...
What was that?
Oh.
Okay.
Yay!
We killed one person!
Whoa!
We killed two!
Fuck, okay.
I need to go there.
I really need to focus up.
I'm, like, not happy with my freezes.
Or maybe it's because I just...
I've just been playing it way too long.
Oh my god!
Ahhhh!
God, get me off this point.
I missed Doki when she could land freezes.
You remember those good old days?
This is real fucking boy!
Ha!
Oh my god, I landed somebody.
I...
I did it.
But I'll die.
We have...
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm low-key now.
No!
It's not fine!
I played too long!
I can't land freezes!
One, two, zero!
Time to switch things up!
Including which side you're on.
I am Loki.
What'd you do to Sentry?
I have no idea.
Bro, it's just...
That's so random!
Who's Tony?
Who the fuck is Tony?
Wait, Tony McLaren?
I got...
Oh yeah!
Fuck that guy!
Oh yeah, no!
No, I hate him too!
No, fuck that guy, dude!
Has everyone got beef with this guy?
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah.
Gormans told me about him.
Fuck that guy.
Fuck that guy in 30 seconds!
Stay strong!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
How nice of you to join out Ilyana.
No, that's a fucking lie!
What have you been doing?
Helping to run a sovereign mutant nation.
And I just had a manicure.
The battle starts in five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
You have to stop them from securing the missionary.
Alright.
So there are two dudes, huh?
Sounds like overpopulation.
They're all so cute.
Yep, you're ready to go, Luna.
I'm gonna go in three, two, one.
Let's go.
Alright.
Had to use that, I guess.
Oh, Mr. Fan.
Oh, no support.
Yes.
Alright.
I have to reload.
Come on, the support.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, that scared me.
Oh, I can't do anything.
Noooooooooooo!
Oh my- oh, they're going hard, time.
Yeah, did you see that?
I was like, what happened?
My sound was gone.
I feel like we're not focusing targets.
My sound was, like, gone.
That was weird.
No, I- I- I was like, what happened?
I'm Mr. Fantastic as well.
And we're not getting anything.
I was so confused.
I am ready to put on a show!
It's Hooper!
Your
powers are mine!
I have to play him.
I don't understand.
Oh my god, nice.
I'll patch you up.
Okay.
Um.
I- I tried.
Oh wait, nice, okay.
Okay.
All right.
Four more minutes of hell.
My favorite.
Oh, never mind.
Hello.
We shall help each other now.
I have to fucking fight back, though.
Loki is so stressful sometimes.
I don't know how to play Loki correctly.
All right.
Nice.
Not nice.
Never mind.
Let's stop being nice.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't understand.
Oh my god, please.
My lap was gone instantly.
My lap disappeared so fast.
That's right.
I have many faces.
Whoa.
No.
Jesus Christ.
Please, I can't, I can't position anymore.
No!
Luki died at 99!
Our rocket died at 99!
And our strange died at 99 too, that's so sad!
Oh my god, it just got off!
One, two, two!
I hate playing against Dive.
Literally, they went... they went more Dive.
Oh my god!
Their Dive was just... so much more intense!
I wish... I missed when they played Widow.
Why didn't he say Widow?!
Oh my god!
Why didn't they say Widow?!
No.
I have one more life.
If we lose this, then like, it's back to... we go try to get it back.
Hahaha!
Literally, the Rockin and I, we were literally...
We were literally trying so hard.
I felt like their... their backline didn't have to go through the shit I just went through.
They... their backline went through more fucking hell.
Like, their backline was just relaxed.
My backline...
My backline was like, fucked up.
Me and the Rocket... could not survive.
Which hero do you think you wanna be today?
Oh, I didn't see.
Guys, was there a level 64?
Because I was not paying attention.
It's two times.
I'm using a bathroom.
I'm using a bathroom a lot because I've been hydrating a lot.
Who
am I gonna banish from this match?
What are we banning?
Are we keeping torch?
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Alright, I'm back.
Wait.
What is this?
Oh, we don't have torch.
I'm still going invis.
I've had it.
If I get dive...
I can right-click.
Oh my god, it's...
the shit again.
It's time.
Guys, look!
I'm squirting everywhere!
When this battle is won, Grant me the honor of investing you in combat.
Okay, buddy.
It's the little things in life that give people joy.
Let him have this.
It's...
Small things in life.
If this is what makes him happy, then let him have that.
If that is truly what brings him joy, then so be it.
Let him enjoy...
what life has to offer.
Yeah, I need to focus.
Okay guys, I'm gonna focus up this time.
I'm so...
What?
Oh, it's cause he like, got off of it.
I was gonna say, how the fuck...
There you go.
Fight on the thing!
Jingle jangle jangle!
Fight on the giant shield!
I got you!
You see that shield?
Jingle jangle jangle!
Jingle jangle!
There you go.
Jingle j...
Okay.
Where is my...
Luna?
Oh!
My Luna died.
I'll fight for my family until the end.
Jingle jangle jangle!
Alright, um...
What?
Where's my Luna?
Oh, there she is.
Okay, um...
I don't...
Oh my god, please.
Oh!
That's awkward.
Oh my god, that's awkward.
I...
That is...
Oh my god, and I got kicked against the wall.
Oh my god, double kick!
Okay, sorry.
Alright.
Please.
Jesus Christ, please.
Alright.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is...
Not okay, but it's fine.
Clearly...
Oh my god.
That's so unlucky.
That's actually so unlucky.
Oh, wait.
I see nine.
Nice.
Please.
Oh my god.
The...
Please.
I have to...
This is my heals.
This is my only source of heals.
Holy shit.
I have no other source of heals.
I'm just like...
I guess I die.
Yippee!
I pushed the cart.
Wait, what a bubble!
You're the best!
Oh my god!
It's like a little...
Amusement park ride!
Yay!
It is good against Dive.
That's why I fucking went in this.
Because I knew they were gonna go Dive.
Like, I knew, like, God hates me and that...
It would be Dive, yet again.
It's always Dive.
Nice deep freeze.
It's almost there!
This is real fire power!
What?
Disappear!
Oh my god!
How?
It's gone!
My shield!
Travel, travel.
What's he doing?
What?
Okay.
That's good.
Good.
She wasted that.
That's not good.
She's dead.
Oh my god.
Please.
I am peeling you as much.
I want you to know your entire life has been peeled.
Oh my god.
I'm actually trying so hard to peel for her.
You don't understand.
Oh my god.
We live here now.
We live here.
I had to use that.
I didn't want our luna to die.
I had not enough heals for her here.
Please.
Where is the Psylocke?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Sorry.
I have to like super concentrate there.
I had to actually super focus that.
I... Dive is like...
Dive is like such a thing where my mind had to be like...
Please don't die.
I'm just like... Please don't die.
Please.
Just... Please don't die.
I'm... I'm putting everything I got into you.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
That was...
Jesus Christ.
The thing is, I can't use my shield for like anything else, but mostly for...
Oh my god.
That should have been.
I'm sad.
That was... that should have been a kill.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Yay!
Oh, not yet!
No!
Not yet!
Alright, I spoke too soon.
Guys, it was in fact... not yet.
It was... it was... unfortunately not yet.
Please.
Oh my god.
Not yet.
Just stay in this.
I hate Dive.
What?
Oh my god.
I...
Please.
How are any of them still alive?
I hate Dive.
The current score is...
3...
2...
0...
It's still not Dive.
Down to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Dive is...
Dive is a very...
Oh my god.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Dive is honestly...
Dive is...
Oh...
Hahahaha.
Aura!
Thank you for the 500 biddies.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
That's alright.
Oh, man.
I worked so hard, and then he decides to throw.
I love Marvel... She clearly... Peak Marvel Rivals experience right there.
Hahaha!
Clearly, that's my Marvel Rivals!
Guys, that's why I played in this.
Because...
Because with Dive Meta, it's just not as fun playing Luna.
Because unless... In this, I can control my fate more.
Three, two, one!
That's my Marvel Rivals!
Coward.
Hahaha!
He didn't commit.
If you're gonna rage bait, at least commit a little.
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
I'm...
There we go.
That's right.
That's what I like to see.
That's what I like to see!
Real rage bait!
Hahaha!
That's right!
Alright.
What?
Oh, okay.
Cool.
What?
I've got your back.
All prey has been... What?
Um...
What's... It gives you more ELO if you plus F5.
What's going... What?
Bro, it doesn't matter what I do.
I can't lose.
Even though I can go 0 and 20, I still won't lose.
I'm too good.
What the fuck is going on?
I'm locked on zero hours of sleep.
I'm crashing the fuck out.
I don't think he's okay.
Nobody cares.
Whoa!
I'm not doing good.
No, no, no.
I'm not pushing you after this game.
Denny, it's okay.
Bro!
I can't even wake up and burst my teeth.
Bro, what'd you say?
I'm getting on, bro.
I don't... Nobody likes you.
What'd you say?
Nobody likes you.
Why didn't you mute them?
That's the first thing I did when I went to the game.
You have a mute option.
Oh, oh, he muted me, right?
What the... Everybody get on that.
What the fuck is going on?
That's the first thing I did as soon as he said it's crap.
Bye.
What the fuck?
Like, what...
What?
I love marble rivals.
The peak rivals experience.
Let's go.
It's bad.
I'm just... I'll just be here.
I believe in him.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's so big!
It's so big!
Hello.
Goodbye.
I'm running a lap.
Wait, how have I been left...
Wait, how have I been left?
NOOOO!
No, you are left!
What is going on?
What?
Okay, I think...
I think this...
I think...
I don't understand what is going on.
I think this...
Bro, the enemy team is throwing too!
What do you do?
Why don't you do that?
I'm gonna go duo with 7.62 and I love 7.62.
What the?
7.62, do you wanna duo?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, 7.62 and you are...
Okay, I have this relationship drama right here.
I have some random ass fucking relationship drama.
But, with some...
With, like, some...
E-couple.
It's some...
Like...
What are they called?
Is it E-couple?
Is this what E-couples are like?
Is it...
Is that what they are called?
E-daters, yes!
E-daters!
I just saw...
I think I witnessed, like, a very toxic E-dating relationship.
Like...
I just...
Is this what E-dating in Rivals is like?
Is it...
It's gotta be...
I think...
I think that is...
E-daters making it everybody's problem.
Yeah...
I think that's the sign.
The E-daters ruined my stream.
I gotta get off now.
I...
GG's GG things...
Thanks the...
Wait...
Don't end it on the E-daters!
Guys, if I'm, like, at a time where, like, e-dating... I'm at the random e-dating scene in Rivals now, I've hit the point where, like, I'm at the queue hours where, like, e-daters are playing at d-gen hours right now, having a public fight in a rake lobby.
And then, at that point, I realized I've hit my newest low.
That is the low I've hit, and I should stop there.
That's when I know I needed to stop there.
I don't even know what half of the things they were arguing... I don't even know what they were arguing about.
Like, they were, like, you were begging me to hop on, spamming me, and now you're throwing my game.
And I'm, like, I'm just, like, what the fuck is going on?
Like, I couldn't process it correctly.
Um, you're right.
It's free content.
Look, I came here to game and for Brotalk.
I'm not here for e-daters.
If I wanted, if I wanted to experience the, the wildlife of e-daters, I'd, I'd go to Valorant.
There's a reason why we're in Rivals right now.
I'd go to Valorant, or, or, we see them in Overwatch, where they do a Cassidy-Mercy duo, and then I ban that shit.
That's crazy.
Valorant e-dating is just people calling each other kidding and shit?
Oh my god.
Wait.
That's so, oh my god.
Now, for Marvel Rivals, for Marvel Rivals, it really does reflect just how toxic it was.
Like, it really did.
Wait, I have a hype train?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Wait, that's awkward.
That's...
Oh wait, it's incoming.
Alright, no, alright.
I don't have to worry about it.
It hasn't even started yet.
It hasn't even started, so...
That means I can end.
Alright, guys.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBaid.
I used to stream on YouTube.
I was streaming on YouTube earlier, and then I did 12 hours of Rivals, and I did like four to five more hours of...
I did like five more hours of Rivals here.
Sarah!
God damn it, guys!
Sarah, thank you for the gifted sub.
Thank you.
Bro sub.
Thank you for the hundred videos.
Thank you.
Okay, well, there's a hype train now.
Okay, that's awkward.
Perfection!
Thank you for the gifted sub.
Thank you.
But yeah, okay.
I was not...
Whoops.
Okay, I guess I'll be here a little longer.
No, we're not doing one...
Okay, if we're doing one more game, I'll do one quick play.
I'm not...
I'll do one quick play, guys.
I am...
I now know what kind of hours this is.
I went through so much in those 16 hours, and the e-dating scene was what made me realize I had to stop.
No one escapes hell.
No, we...
Like, I don't understand.
Why did the enemy team start throwing?
I...
I don't understand.
What...
What happened on the other side?
I just don't want to hear.
I just don't want to...
I mean, like...
I don't know.
It was like...
They were, like, arguing, too.
So it was like...
You know, like, those moments where you're like that...
Okay, this seems like a very, like, specific...
Like, specific thing.
You're at a friend's house, and then your friend and their mom is arguing or something.
And all you can do is just sit there awkwardly.
Um...
Do it...
Looking at your phone while your friend and your mom argues in the background.
Because you're sort of, like, stuck there.
And you can't really go home.
Because you have to...
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
I was just...
Like, it's such a random, passive-aggressive fight.
But...
Yeah, yeah.
I was just like...
What the fuck is...
I was like...
What am I supposed to do here?
No!
His hammer fucking moved his...
Okay, nice.
I have to reload.
That sucks.
I have to deal with Captain America in fucking quickly!
I already have to deal with him!
And now I have to deal with him in fucking quickly!
Like...
Bro!
Do you not have enough fun in Ring?
Alright.
That's fine.
We gotta wait until the hype train is over.
And then we can go...
And then we can all go home.
And then we play Super Mario, man.
Oh my god, the double stun.
Whoops!
Don't worry, I got you guys.
Yay!
Oh my god, Blackfire!
Thank you for that!
Thank you for the five gift of subs!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Wait, he just got out of that.
I'll use that later.
Dink, dink, dink.
What the fuck?
That should be a dink!
What?
Okay, I'm definitely no ready.
There's no way.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
Please don't hit me.
I'm just a little guy.
Can I hit them all the way from there?
God damn it, I can.
No!
He was...
Oh god!
Oh no.
It's fine.
I'm safe.
I'm not safe.
Oh my god.
Three, four people died.
We were not safe.
I feel it!
Thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you!
Guys, we were not safe, guys.
I made a mistake.
Hey guys!
Thank you for the two gifted subs!
Thank you!
You know what's crazy?
I've hit my fifth win.
You need to stop that vehicle.
I'm technically not tired.
How tiny is your fucking head?!
Oh my god!
Oh, he's...
Yeah, I was gonna stay.
Did you miss?
Oh, okay.
Nope.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
He was...
Okay.
I was like...
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, he missed.
He didn't miss that.
You were talking shit.
Alright, look.
I...
Might have spoke too soon.
I was like watching him miss and...
Look.
He hit the shot when...
When he needed to.
I agree.
Good for him.
Why?!
Oh my god!
He fucking booted him off!
Okay.
Okay, I'm just gonna be here and I'm gonna farm it here.
Until...
That's fine.
Stop booting him when I'm angling headshots!
It's actually fucked up.
Every time I have like the perfect headshot...
Jesus Christ, he lives forever!
He's gonna wait until...
Fantastic!
There we go.
Where is he?
I shall eliminate you!
Nice.
Alright, there we go.
He is so fucking tanky.
It made me realize how much I...
I fucking hate it.
Why am I still in East Coast?
Where are my West Coast gamers?
Yeah, my ping is so high because like...
I don't know if you guys know this, but NA is really fucking big.
I should've just done...
I should've just done only West Coast.
Yeah, I'm one of those people.
The fact that...
No.
EU people almost get the same ping as me when I queue East Coast.
When they queue East Coast, it's almost the same ping.
That's what's the most fucked up part.
The fact that we share like the same connection.
Even though technically...
They are further away from me.
Hey guys, thank you for the two gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Don't worry, I'm shooting the wall.
I'm doing something that no other people would do.
Because I know the support pain.
Of a guy that doesn't shoot the fucking wall.
Heal me, you simpletons.
I am barely harmed.
Get over here, Jacob.
Oh wait, you get healed?
That's legal.
That's fine, I got that one squid.
We got the one squid, yes.
It's okay.
We got the one squid!
There we go.
That's right!
That's...
Get over here!
Oh, never mind.
My team's dead, guys.
Guys, my team's may or may not be dead.
Goodbye, everyone.
I shall wash them, I'll die.
Oh my god, I almost wanted to get that raccoon kill!
Uh, Catgirl, thank you for the tier 1 sub!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey guys, thank you for another two gifted subs!
Oh my god, by the time I finish this, the hype train's gonna be over.
Nice, good timing.
I've hit my 5th win, so I'm not...
You know when you hit your 5th win, you're not tired?
Unfortunately, that's me right now.
Oh, that's not good.
I'm so sure that I am very hot.
God damn it.
Oh, there's too many squids!
Nooooo!
Oh, these squids!
That's it!
I'm trying now!
That's fucking it!
What do you mean this is my best DPS?
Well, Psylocke is, but my hands can't...
Doesn't feel like aiming right now.
I think, like...
Doesn't feel like doing, like, fast aiming at the moment.
Like, this is a lot easier.
It's a lot easier.
Cause I can do this.
And then that does my aim for me.
Like, I...
Look at that.
That aims for me.
Get over here, Luna!
Get over here!
That's fucking right!
Get your ass over here!
Easiest fucking character of my life!
Get out of here!
No, it is.
This character is so easy.
Oh, just cause you're in a fog?
Think I won't kill you?
I'm coming after you, Luna!
Oh, shit!
You live for now!
I saw the hell out of that.
I was like, okay, nevermind.
Nevermind!
You can...
You can have that.
Get over here, Dora.
Don't worry.
I shall speed you out.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?!
Okay!
That was a hate crime, too.
Alright.
Don't worry.
It's over time.
Things will always be okay if it's over time.
Oh, I can do this.
Yay!
Get out of here!
Oh!
This is a good ultrar to me, too.
Wait, what?
How did my team die?
By the way, I don't know if you guys know this, but...
Please don't look up!
Please don't...
What the fuck?!
It's...
Spider Time!
Oh, no.
I have to wait until after Spider Time's over.
Because, um...
If I actually...
They don't know.
Told you they don't know.
What if I just spawn camp the Luna?
I'm just gonna spawn...
Actually...
No, I should try.
I was, like, thinking, like...
I could literally just spawn camp the Luna.
But then I'm like, nah.
Yeah.
Now I spawn camp the Luna.
Now I sp...
That's fucked.
Fuck that living head in particular.
Yay!
I did my job.
Um...
She's the one...
I will not stop the cycle!
Can't quit on a win.
I'm ready to leave.
Agent, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Sumi, thank you for the tier one sub.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
That was a long stream.
I don't mean to do a long stream.
But something just hit me today.
I...
Some...
I got, like...
Sometimes I get into these weird...
Uh...
FPS shooters.
Or, like, whatever.
Because it's not FPS.
Shooter addiction.
And this was my...
I got into...
I got into the groove.
I...
Alright.
Hey, guys!
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
Feel free to check me on YouTube.
I'm mostly streaming over there.
Uh...
Today was a special day.
I was just feeling more into...
I was feeling more into...
You know, streaming with some more rivals.
Got really into it for some fucking reason.
It just, like, bit me in my head.
Uh...
Sorry, it's...
Um...
How do I phrase this lightly?
Sorry, I'm clinically addicted to...
To...
Rank sometimes.
And, like...
Um...
And I relapsed a little bit.
But don't worry.
I'm fine.
I...
I got out of my system.
And I should be okay now.
Uh...
But, yes.
If you wanna know whenever I'm going live on Twitch, feel free to follow me on Twitter.
I should tweet out whenever I'm live on Twitch.
Um...
What else do I wanna say?
Okay.
Um...
If you wanna support me via other means, feel free to check out my merch.
Uh...
I have, like, several stuff.
Like, hide PC cases.
Um...
Everything.
And, uh...
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-gamer subcode.
Dokiberry for 10% off.
Uh...
And, yeah.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
As always, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Is it up for me?
Head to bed.
Cuz...
You deserve it.
I'm not gonna raid anyone today.
Just...
Go disperse to wherever you wanna go to.
Um...
Wherever the land...
Whatever...
Wherever the land wants you to go to.
Oh wait, is Rixi streaming?
Yeah, I'll just...
You know what?
I'll...
I'll raid Rixi.
He...
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'll raid.
I'll raid him.
He's the guy I dueled with.
Uh...
The EU guy I dueled with.
Where...
People...
Where that one guy was like...
Fuck you, Rixi in particular.
Okay, that was pretty silly.
When he was like...
Um...
I thought that was funny.
When he was like...
I hate my team.
But I especially hate Rixi on the enemy team.
And I'm just thinking like...
What the fuck did he do?
I was like...
Why in particular him?
Like...
Then Rixi's like...
I don't even know this guy.
Uh...
But I'll raid him.
Anyway...
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!